THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND TODAY'S
HEARING IS FOCUSED ON HEALTH
FOR ALL I'VE BEEN ASKED TO READ
SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION ALL
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY TODAY AND THERE WILL
BE NO VOTE IN THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ALSO
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING ON THE INTERNET
THE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
1-877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2890 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU ALL PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
TAKING ON THE ISSUES ON THE
AGENDA INCLUDING THE NON
PRESENTATION ISSUES ISSUES SIX
THROUGH THIRTEEN AT THE END OF
THE HEARING UPON CONCLUSION. OF
PANEL FIVE. AS WE BEGIN TODAY.
I DO WANNA. HAVE SOME OPENING
REMARKS. THIS IS A DEFINING
MOMENT FOR OUR STATE. HOW THE
NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION
RESPONDS TO THIS PANDEMIC OF
THE CENTURY AND WHAT CHANGES WE
MAKE TO RISE OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. STRONGER ARE HOW HE
WILL BE REMEMBERED. SO WE MUST
START BY ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THIS PANDEMIC HAS NOT HIT US
ALL EQUALLY. SOME HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SHELTER IN PLACE AND
WORK FROM HOME WHILE OTHERS
HAVE BEEN LABELED ESSENTIAL
WORKERS HAVE EXPOSED THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES. THE
DISPARITIES PARTICULARLY FOR
ARE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY THAT
WE WILL HEAR ABOUT LATER OUR
DEEP AND WIDE. BUT ARE NOT
SURPRISING. WE KNOW THAT THOSE
WHO LACK INSURANCE GET SICKER
AND THEY DIE SOONER. THIS
PANDEMIC WHICH HAS MAGNIFIED
AND EXACERBATE EXACERBATED
UNDERLYING HEALTH DISPARITIES
THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED LATINOS AND OUR
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY. FORCE
US NOW TO ASK HOW CAN WE CHANGE
SYSTEMS TO IMPROVE FOR THE NEXT
CRISIS. WE KNOW THAT THE
LARGEST SEGMENT OF OUR STATE'S
REMAINING UNINSURED IS OUR
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY THAT HAS CONTINUED TO
DO THE ESSENTIAL WORK NEEDED
FOR OUR STATE TO HAVE A
BOUNTIFUL HARVEST BUT WHO HAVE
NOT HAD THEIR OWN BASIC
ESSENTIAL NEEDS. TAKEN CARE OF.
CENTRAL TO THAT IS THE BASIC
HUMAN RIGHT TO HEALTH CARE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. FOR US TO DIRECTLY AND
SERIOUSLY ADDRESS EQUITY THUS
AFFECTING THE DISPARITIES BORN
OUT IN THIS PANDEMIC WE MUST
WORK TOWARDS UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
AS OUR NORTH STAR. WE MUST AT A
MINIMUM MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT TO
PROTECT OUR ELDERS AND SENIORS
FROM THE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNIY
THIS YEAR WHILE WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON HOW TO
ACTUALIZE A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
BUT THIS BEGS THE QUESTION.
WILL THE GOVERNOR MAKE
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE A
PRIORITY CAN MAKE ALL THE
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS TO KEEP
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE AND
HELP. THIS IS HIS LEGACY. THIS
IS HOW HE WILL BE REMEMBERED HI
STAND READY TO ROLL UP MY
SLEEVES TO PUT FAITH AND WORKS
INTO ACTION TO ACHIEVE
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE. WITH
THAT FRAMING LET'S BEGIN
TODAY'S HERE. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH A PANEL ONE ON HEALTH FOR
ALL. FOR THOSE PANELISTS OR
PRESENTERS PLEASE PRESENT IN
THE ORDER THEIR NAME APPEARS ON
THE AGENDA. WE WILL HOLD ALL
MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
THE PRESENTERS HAVE CONCLUDED.
LET'S BEGIN WITH JOSE TORRES
FROM HEALTHAXIS. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSE TORRES
ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION AND A CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT OF EXPANDING FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL. ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
ADULTS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR FULL SCOPE MEDICAL
COVERAGE THAT PROVIDES ACCESS
TO ROUTINE PRIMARY AND
PREVENTIVE CARE. THEY ARE ONLY
ELIGIBLE FOR RESTRICTED SCOPE
MEDIC HOW WHICH COVERS
EMERGENCY ROOM CARE. THE
EMERGENCY ROOM IS THE LEAST
EFFICIENT MOST EXPENSIVE WAY TO
PROVIDE CARE AND NOT A
SUBSTITUTE FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE BENEFITS COVERED
UNDER FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL. AS A
RESULT UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS
REMAIN UNINSURED LIVE CENTER
THANK YOUNG- AND R. ONE MEDICAL
EMERGENCY AWAY FROM FINANCIAL
RUIN. WE NEED COVERAGE AND CARE
NOW ESPECIALLY PANDEMIC THAT
EXACERBATES EXISTING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS AND HAS TARGETED THE
SAME COMMUNITIES OF ESSENTIAL
AND EXPOSE WORKERS. BY
EXPANDING MEDIC HOUSE WITH ALL
INDOCUMENTADOS WE CAN CLOSE ONE
OF THE LARGEST REMAINING
COVERAGE GAPS AND STRENGTHEN
THE HEALTH SYSTEM THAT WE ALL
RELY ON. WE WOULD TAKE A LARGE
STEP TO ENSURE EVERYONE DAHLE
IN OUR STATE HAS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE WHEN THEY NEED IT
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY WERE
BORN. FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
YOU TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
AND ANY HEALTH. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM ORVILLE
THOMAS. CIBC GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
OUR HEALTH FOR ALL CAMPAIGN AND
THE PRESSING NEED TO PUSH FOR A
MEDIC CAL EXPANSION TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS MY
NAME IS WARFEL THOMAS AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER I ALSO
SERVE AS A MEMBER OF THE
STATE'S COMMUNITY BAXEEN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. OVER THE
LAST YEAR DURING COPE IT.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS HAVE
MADE UP A DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT OF WORKERS DEEMED AS
ESSENTIAL. THEY HAVE CONTINUE
TO PUT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES AT RISK TO SERVE
THE STATE AND TO KEEP OUR
ECONOMY MOVING. THIS WORK OFTEN
HAPPENED AND CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN DESPITE LIMITED ACCESS
TO BASIC WORKER PROTECTIONS. PP
AND WITH IMMIGRANT WORKERS
TYPICALLY LIVING IN COMMUNITIES
THAT LACK BASIC HEALTH
ESSENTIALS. THIS IS ALSO HAS
HAPPENED TO A POPULATION THAT
HAS HISTORICALLY NOT HAD ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE LEAVING THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO THE CORONA VIRUS
SINCE THEY HAD. MORE UNDERLYING
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
COMORBIDITIES THAT THEY DID NOT
KNOW ABOUT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
PREVENTIVE CARE. AND NOW IS WE
ARE STARTING TO THINK THROUGH
THE VACCINATION FUEL RECOVERY
IS IMPORTANT NOTE THAT
IMMIGRANT WORKERS ARE STILL
FALLING BEHIND. AS THEY ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED. IN
VACCINATION RATES COMPARED TO
THEIR PERCENTAGE OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION. AND ON
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY IT
WOULD BE NEGLIGENT. TO NOT
MENTION THAT IMMIGRANT WMEN
HAVE BEEN MOST AFFECTED OR MORE
AFFECTED THAN THEIR WHITE
CONTEMPORARIES DURING COATED
WITH JOBS IN RESTAURANTS
HOSPITALITY HEALTHCARE BEING
CUT. WITHOUT A PROMISE OF FIRST
RETURN OR POSSIBILITY TO TURN
TO THOSE JOBS AT ALL. I
UNDERSTAND THE PUSH FROM
COMMUNITIES IN ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO GET BACK TO A
SENSE OF NORMAL AND TO BE IN
OUR LONG NEEDED RECOVERY. BUT
WE MUST NOT USE BACK TO NORMAL
AS A STANDARD WE MUST GET BACK
TO SOMETHING BETTER. THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS CALIFORNIA POLICY
CENTER AND OUR PARTNERS AT
HEALTH ACCESS. HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY WORKED WITH
LEGISLATORS AND TWO GOVERNORS
TO EXPAND HEALTH CARECOVERAGE
TO PREVIOUSLY UNINSURED
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE HELD FOR
ALL KIDS AND HEALTH FOR ALL
YOUNG ADULTS CAMPAIGN. THERE
ARE NOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
THROUGH THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE.
THAT CAN RECEIVE MEDICAL
COVERAGE IF THEIR INCOME
ELIGIBLE. AS SUCCESSFUL AS
THOSE CAMPAIGNS WERE THEY
DIDN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT OR
IMMEDIATELY. IT TOOK A PUSH
FROM OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
AND A VULNERABILITY TO SHARE
THEIR STORIES OF DEATH AND
LOSS. NOW IS THE TIME TO FINISH
THE CAMPAIGNS THAT WE STARTED
AND GROW FROM SOME TO ALL. THIS
ISSUE IS ALSO TIMELY AS THERE
IS A FEDERAL PARTNER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND A DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESS. THAT POLITICAL
ALIGNMENT MAY ALLOW FOR THE
STATE TO START THE INVESTMENT
IN HEALTH CARE EXPANSION AND
WORK ON FUTURE COST SAVINGS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO THIS
CAUSE AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF OUR STATES UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION. THIS HEARING AND
THE TESTIMONY FROM WITNESSES
WILL HOPEFULLY HELP BRING THIS
HEALTHCARE TO EVERY
CALIFORNIANS. BY ELIMINATING
THE BARRIERS BASED ON WHERE
SOMEONE WAS BORN. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
YOUR EFFORT TO ENSURE HEALTH
FOR ALL. NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
LAUREL LUCILA. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND I HAVE SOME SLIDES TO SHARE
I SEE I CAN SHOW THEM NOW. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAUREL
THIS YEAR I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE HEALTH CARE PROGRAM AT THE
UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY ON THE REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. I WANTED TO
START BY BRIEFLY ACKNOWLEDGING
HOW INTEGRAL AND DOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE TO OUR STATE.
THE TWO POINT ONE MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED- CALIFORNIANS MAKE
UP A SIGNIFICANT PART OF OUR
WORK FORCE. THEY PAY BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN TAXES EACH YEAR.
AND MOST ARE LONG TERM
RESIDENTS WITH STRONG ROOTS IN
THE STATE AND THEY'RE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FAMILIES.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AT UC BERKELEY AND
UCLA WE PROJECTED HOW MANY
CALIFORNIANS WOULD BE UNINSURED
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO AFTER A
D. IMPORTANT STATE ACTIONS WERE
TAKEN TO REMOVE THE STATE
CLOSER TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
WE ESTIMATED THAT THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS I
WOULD BE UNANSWERED AFTER AS
YOUNG ADULTS EXPANSION THE
STATE AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THROUGH COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND AFTER THIS STATE.
MANDATE WAS IMPLEMENTED. BUT
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS AT
MAKE UP THE LARGEST GROUP OF
UNINSURED AS- AROUND ONE POINT
THREE MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE UNINSURED. AND
THEY MAKE UP THE LARGEST GROUP
BECAUSE THEY'RE EXCLUDED FROM
ACA AND MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY
UNDER FEDERAL POLICY AND
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE OFFERED A JOB
BASED COVERAGE BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS. LAUREL ARE YOU
PUBLIC LORALAI I APOLOGIZE- WE
HAVE A PRESENTER WHO NEEDS TO
PRESENT AND I WENT OUT OF ORDER
SO- IT'S- NOT TRADITIONAL BUT I
MAY ASK YOU TO PAUSE YOUR
PRESENTATION YES OKAY I WILL US
STOP SHARING THE SLIDES AND WE
WILL HAVE WILLIAM SERRANO ALAMO
PRESENT AT THE MOMENT AND WE
WILL COME BACK. RIGHT TO YOU
LAUREL THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE LILIANE IF YOU CAN
BEGIN. THANK YOU. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LILLIAN
SERRANO AND TODAY I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU THE STORY OF AN
ORTHODONTIST. MY MOTHER IN LAW
WHO WAS UNDOCUMENTED AND
UNINSURED LIKE MANY OTHERS IN
OUR STATE. IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN MY FAMILY AND I
SUFFERED THE LOSS OF MY MOTHER
IN LAW AFTER MONTHS OF TRYING
EVERYTHING AVAILABLE TO US TO
GET HER MEDICAL CARE. THE
NATIONAL LEVEL ARRIVE IN
ESCONDIDO CALIFORNIA OVER
TWENTY YEARS SEVERAL. SHE BUILT
A LIFE HERE WITH HER EIGHT KIDS-
MY HUSBAND WHO WAS THE FIRST IN
HIS FAMILY TO GRADUATE WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. AND WEBER
TOOK CARE OF HER KIDS
GRANDCHILDREN AND EVEN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SHE WAS A
COMMUNITY LEADER WHO ALWAYS
STRIVE TO DEMONSTRATION. AND
LOCAL HEARINGS. IT WAS NORMAL
FOR THEM TO HANDLE THEM OUT TO
GO MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS WITHOUT
DOCTORS VISITS. MONTHS BEFORE
HER DEATH SHE STARTED
COMPLAINING OF STRONG ABDOMINAL
PAIN SO WE TOOK HER TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY CLINIC. NONE OF
US COULD HAVE IMAGINED THE
POSSIBILITY THAT WOULD SEEM
LIKE A STOMACH PROBLEM WAS
CALLED BLADDER CANCER. IT WAS A
LONG PROCESS JUST TO GET HER
CLOSE TO A DIAGNOSIS BECAUSE
COMMUNITY CLINICS ARE NOT THE
SIGN FOR THIS CASES. WE NEED A
SPECIALIST AND TESTING THE
CLINIC CAN OFFER. WE TRIED
EVERY PLACE BUT MOST DON'T TAKE
PEOPLE WITHOUT INSURANCE THE
PRICES WERE TOO HIGH IN THE
WAITING TIME WAS TOO LONG. AND
WEBER KEPT COMING IN AND OUT OF
THE LOCAL EMERGENCY ROOM. IT
WAS ONLY AFTER SHE WENT TO THE
ER AT UCSD MEDICAL CENTER SHE
WAS ABLE TO GET A PROPER
ASSESSMENT. AT THAT POINT THE
DOCTOR WAS ABLE TO CONFRONT THE
HARD TRUTH. THAT SHE HAD FINAL
STAGE GALLBLADDER CANCER. THE
DOCTORS THINK THAT THE CANCER
HAD ALREADY BEEN SPREADING FOR
OVER FIVE YEARS. THEY EXPLAINED
TO US THAT THE EARLY SYMPTOMS
COULD HAVE BEEN CONFUSED WITH
DIGESTIVE PROBLEMS. THE
NATIONAL WEBER HAD NEVER
VISITED A DOCTOR FOR HER PAIN
BECAUSE IT WAS OUT OF THE
PROJECT. ONCE SHE HAD FINAL
STAGE CNCER THERE WAS NOTHING
WE COULD DO. NOVEMBER PASSED
AWAY SURROUNDED BY ALL HER KIDS
AND GRAND KIDS ON HER HOSPITAL
BED AFTER TWO WEEKS OF FINALLY
RECEIVING A MEDICAL TREATMENT.
THOSE WERE THE LONGEST AND MOST
PAINFUL WEEKS OF OUR LIVES. THE
WOMAN WHO ARE TAKING CARE OF
ALL OF US EVEN ME GOOD I'M SURE
HER BLOOD WAS ON THE BED IN
PAIN AND THERE WAS NOTHING WE
COULD DO. WE ALL KEPT ASKING
OURSELVES WHAT SHE COULD HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY COUNT ON
REGULAR DOCTORS VISITS. OR EVEN
WHEN SHE FELT THE STOMACH PAIN.
WHAT IS SHE WAS NOT
UNDOCUMENTED DOES SHE HAVE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE IT'S A MATTER OF
LIFE AND DEATH. GETTING A
PROPER MEDICAL CARE EARLY COULD
HAVE PREVENTED THE LOSS OF THE
NATIONAL GUERRA A COMMUNITY
LEADER WHO WAS THE HEART OF OUR
FAMILY. WE WOULDN'T NEED TO SEE
HER SUFFER WITHOUT A WAY OF
PREVENTING OR STOPPING HER
PAIN. WE WOULDN'T BE LEFT WITH
UNPAID MEDICAL BILLS. MY FAMILY
AND I ADVOCATE FOR HELPFUL FOR
ALL BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
ANYBODY TO EVER EXPERIENCE WHAT
WE WENT THROUGH. WE BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE TO
SUFFER OR DIE FROM A TREATABLE
CONDITION NO MATTER WHERE THEY
WERE BORN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILLIAM FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO LAURA LUCIR.
SERVING THE UNINSURED ESTIMATES
THAT A WAS DISCUSSING I WERE
PUBLISHED IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN AND OF COURSE A LOT OF
CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE CHANGED
SINCE THEN. IT CALIFORNIA WE
SENIOR AND MANY CALIFORNIANS
LOSE JOB BASED COVERAGE DUE TO
LOSING THEIR JOB DURING
CONVENTION AS AND AT THE SAME
TIME MEDICAL ENROLLMENT AND
COVERED CALIFORNIA ENROLLMENT
HAVE GROUND. WE DON'T YET KNOW
WHAT THE NET IMPACT OF THESE
COVERAGE SHIFTS HAS BEEN ON THE
NUMBER OF UNINSURED IN THE
STATE- BUT WHAT'S MOST RELEVANT
TO THIS CONVERSATION TODAY IS
AS HOW HAS THE NUMBER OF
UNDOCUMENTED AND UNINSURED
ADULTS CHANGED- FIRST IT WE'VE
HAD A POSITIVE CHANGE THAT
BETWEEN JANUARY AND OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY. EIGHTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AGES NINETEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE GAMES FULL SCOPE
MEDICAL BENEFITS UNDER THE
YOUNG ADULT EXPANSION. AND THAT
EXPANSION IS ALREADY REFLECTED
AND ARE UNINSURED ESTIMATES. ON
THE OTHER HAND IT'S LIKELY THAT
THERE WERE AND DOCUMENTED
WORKERS. WHO LOST JOBS COVERAGE
DURING THE PANDEMIC WHEN THEY
LOST THEIR JOB WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY- BUT EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC FUEL AND DOCUMENTED
WORKERS HAD JOB BASED COVERAGE
TO BEGIN WITH. AS ON AS A WHOLE
AND IT SEEMS VERY LIKELY TO ME
THAT UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
HAVE CONTINUED TO MAKE UP THE
LARGEST GROUP OF UNINSURED.
EVEN DURING THE PANDEMIC.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THERE IS
CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WERE
EXPERIENCING WORSE ACCESS TO
CARE THIS IS DATA FROM
COLLEAGUES AT UCLA THAT SHOWS
THAT 44% OF UNDOCUMENTED LOW
INCOME ADULTS. HEY DID NOT HAVE
A U. S. USUAL SOURCE OF CARE.
COMPARED 224% OF CITIZENS AND
DOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WITH THE
SAME INCOME LEVEL. AND
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS HAVE
BEEN HARD HIT BY COVERED BOTH
ECONOMICALLY AND HEALTH WISE.
WE DON'T HAVE DATA ON KOBE
CASES AND DEATHS SPECIFICALLY
BY IMMIGRATION STATUS BUT WE
KNOW THAT NONCITIZEN
IMMIGRANTS. LIKE ME AT TO HAVE
CERTAIN RISK FACTORS FOR COBIZ
INCLUDING RISK FACTORS RELATED
TO WORK. A STUDY BY UCSF
RESEARCHERS COMPARED THE ACTUAL
TAX RATES FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKING ADULTS AGE TWENTY FIVE
AND UNDER DURING THE PANDEMIC
TO THE EXPECTED DEATH RATES
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND THEY
FOUND THAT ON AVERAGE THE RISK
OF DEATH. BUT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA ADULTS WITH 22%
HIGHER DURING THE PANDEMIC- BUT
IT WAS EVEN WORSE FOR THOSE WHO
WORK IN OCCUPATIONS THAT ARE
COMMON AMONG NON CITIZENS. WHAT
THIS TABLE SHOWS IS THE FIVE
TOP OCCUPATIONS. FOR NON
CITIZEN WORKERS NATIONALLY. I
FOR CUTS. AS THE MORTALITY RATE
WAS 16% HIGHER DURING THE
PANDEMIC COMPARED TO PRE
PANDEMIC AND THAT WAS THAT THE
OCCUPATION WITH THE VERY
HIGHEST INCREASE AND THE DEATH
RATES. I RECALL CHIRLA WORKERS-
HAD A 55% INCREASE THE
MORTALITY RATE DURING THE
PANDEMIC FOR CONSTRUCTION
LABORS IT WAS FORTY NINE
PRESENTS AND FOR MAIDS AND
HOUSEKEEPERS 33% LATINOS HAVE
ALSO BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC THIS IS DATA FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT REFLECTS ALL
LATINOS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
HIM ARE CITIZENS. HOWEVER
APPROXIMATELY 86% OF
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS ARE
LATINO SO THIS DATA. TELLS US
SOMETHING BROADLY ABOUT HOW
UNDOCUMENTED. LATINO ADULTS-
HAVE FARED DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WELL THAT HE KNOWS OF ALL AGES
HAVE HAD HIGHER RATES OF
TESTING POSITIVE FOR KOBE AND
OF DYING FROM COPE IT AND THE
DISPARITY IS ESPECIALLY SEVERE
UP FOR OLDER LATINO ADULTS FOR
THOSE AGES SIXTY FIVE TO
SEVENTY NINE- THE CHINOS MADE
UP ALMOST HALF OF THE KOBE
DEATHS. BUT ONLY AT 822% OF THE
POPULATION OF THAT AIDS. HE'S A
DISPARITIES IN CODE RELATED
OUTCOMES ARE THE LATEST EXAMPLE
OF LONG STANDING HEALTH
DISPARITIES FOR IMMIGRANTS FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN THE STATE
AND IN THIS COUNTRY. I LACK OF
HEALTH INSURANCE IS LIKELY ONE
OF MANY FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO THESE DISPARITIES. THERE'S
AT LEAST ONE STUDIES THAT
SUGGESTS THAT THERE'S AN
ASSOCIATION BETWEEN OUR- IT AS
AN INSURANCE RATES AND HIGHER
CO THAT CASES AND DEATH RATES
AND THAT'S- NOT SURPRISING
GIVEN THE PAST RESEARCH. THAT
HAS FOUND THAT HAVING INSURANCE
IMPROVE PEOPLE'S USE OF
PREVENTIVE CARE AND WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE INSURANCE THEY GET MORE
REGULAR CARE FOR THEIR CHRONIC
CONDITIONS HAVING INSURANCE HAS
BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH LOWER
MORTALITY RATES. ELEMENT
INSURANCE IMPROVES FINANCIAL
SECURITY AND CREWS WORK FORCE
PRODUCTIVITY AND OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS ARE ALSO
STRONGER WHEN EVERYONE IS
INCLUDED. EXPANDING MEDICAL
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS IS A VERY WELL TARGETED
POLICY. TO ACHIEVING OUR
STATE'S GOAL OF MOVING CLOSER
TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE AND
THAT'S BECAUSE A MAJORITY OF
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE
HEALTH. BASED ON THEIR INCOME
BUT FOR THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS
LACK INSURANCE AND VERY MUCH
NEED THIS POLICY. I ESTIMATE
THAT ONE POINT OH FOUR MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIA ADULTS
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE
L. UNDER AN EXPANSION. AND THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE WHO
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE ARE ALREADY
ENROLLED AND RESTRICTED SCOPE
MEDICS ALL. WHICH COVERS
EMERGENCY AND PREGNANCY RELATED
SERVICES USING FEDERAL AND
STATE DOLLARS. AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR TWO REASONS FIRST
IT MEANS THAT MOST OF THOSE
ELIGIBLE CAN BE AUTOMATICALLY
POSITIONS HAVE FULL BENEFITS
WHEN THE POLICY IS IMPLEMENTED
AS WAS DONE- WITH THE EXPANSION
OF CHEN DOCUMENTED CHILDREN AND
YOUNG ADULTS. AND SECONDLY THIS
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE A LARGE
PART OF THE COST IS ALREADY
BEING COVERED. GIVEN THAT
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
PREGNANCY RELATED SERVICES ARE
AMONG. THE MORE EXPENSIVE TYPES
OF CARE. UNDER AN EXPANSION
ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIA ADULTS
WOULD BE EXPECTED TO ENROLL IN
THE SYSCO GUEST ON THOSE AGES
IT HAS TWENTY SIX IN A- AND
THIS REFLECTS. MOSTLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALREADY ENROLLED IN
RESTRICTED SCOPE BENEFITS CLASS
I ASSUME THAT HALF OF THOSE
ELIGIBLE BUT NOT ENROLLED WITH
NEARLY A ROLL. AND AMONG AMONG
THESE AND ROWLEY'S TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND ARE. AGES SIXTY FIVE
PLUS. SO TO SUMMARIZE MY THREE
BECAUSE A POINTS YESTERDAY
WHERE THAT UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO BE THE
LARGEST GROUP OF UNINSURED IN
THE STATE. AND THAT A
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC- AS IS SUGGESTED BY
THE DATA ON THE OCCUPATIONS
WITH THE HIGHEST MORTALITY
RATES DURING THE CANS AT MAC.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT IF
ELIGIBILITY WERE EXPANDED
NEARLY NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS COULD GAIN FULL
SCOPE MEDICAL COVERAGE AND THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF UNINSURED BY THE STATE IN
THE STATE BY APPROXIMATELY ONE
REPORTER. THANK YOU I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM KATY REBEL FROM
COVERED CALIFORNIA. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND KATIE RAVEL POLICY DIRECTOR
COVERED CALIFORNIA HAPPY TO BE
WITH YOU TODAY TO TALK ABOUT A
COVER CALIFORNIA AND ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
ENROLLMENT TRENDS AND RECENT
FEDERAL ACTIONS AND POLICY
CHANGES THAT MAY IMPACT OUR
PROGRAM. AS YOU KNOW THE
AFFORDABLE CHARACTER MAGICALLY
CHANGE THE INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET WHICH IS WELL
SUB- SUMMARIZED IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S AGENDA FOR
TODAY. A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WAS THE
CREATION OF HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE'S THROUGH WHICH
ELIGIBLE AMERICANS CAN PURCHASE
HEALTH INSURANCE FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND ACCESS.
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES TO REDUCE
THEIR MONTHLY PREMIUMS AND OUT
OF POCKET COSTS. COVER
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
BENEFIT EXCHANGE IS THE LARGEST
STATE RUN EXCHANGE INFORMATION
WITH OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN ROYALTIES. TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA ENACTED FOR
FIRST STATE BASED PREMIUM
SUBSIDY PROGRAM FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH INCOMES OVER 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. THAT ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES TODAY. THE PROGRAM
ALSO PROVIDES INCREASED
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH INCOME BELOW 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN THE SECOND YEAR
THAT THREE YEAR PROGRAM. AND
NOW MOVES TO ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC ON OUR INVOLVEMENT
AND THEN I'LL RETURN TO THE
STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM IN A FEW
MOMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THE AND AT THAT PENDING FEDERAL
STIMULUS LEGISLATION. AS OF
JANUARY NEARLY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAD EITHER
RENEWED OR SIGNED UP FOR NEW
COVERAGE FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
IN THIS REPRESENTED A HIGH
WATER MARK FOR OUR INVOLVEMENT
OVER THE LIFE OF OUR PROGRAM-
THE NUMBER ALSO REPRESENTS A
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. POINT-
INCREASING PLANTS. OF THE SAME
TIME PERIOD LAST YEAR. OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP 90% RECEIVE
FINANCIAL HELP INCLUDING SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND WHO
RECEIVED STATE SUBSIDIES. AND
OF THOSE STATE SUBSIDY
RECIPIENTS NEARLY FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND ARE MIDDLE INCOME
CONSUMERS BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED
AND 6100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL WHO WOULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL SUBSIDIES I
AM REALLY I HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM OUR STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM.
SO LET ME NOW ADDRESS WHAT
COVER CALIFORNIA DID ADMIT
COVERAGE MORE ACCESSIBLE DURING
THE PANDEMIC. OF FIRST WE ACTED
QUICKLY IN TWENTY TWENTY. TO
ENSURE THAT ALL IMPACTED AN
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS WERE ABLE
TO SIGN UP FOR COVERAGE. WE DID
THIS BY IMPLEMENTING A SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT PERIOD THAT SPANNED
FROM MARCH TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. TO AUGUST THIRTY FIRST.
WE ALSO DURING THAT TIME
INVESTED NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN A PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
KNEW OF THE AVAILABILITY OF OUR
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIOD. AND
DURING THAT TIME TWO HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
SIGNED UP FOR COVERAGE. WHICH
WAS MORE THAN TWICE THE NUMBER.
WHO SIGNED UP DURING THAT SAME
PERIOD IN TWENTY NINETEEN. THEN
ON JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH. OF
THIS YEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
ESTABLISHED A FEDERAL SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT PERIOD OF THE STATE
THAT ARE SERVED BY THE FEDERAL
MARKETPLACE. COVERED CALIFORNIA
IN COORDINATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE AND IT DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FOLLOW THIS BY
ANNOUNCING A SPECIALENROLLMENT
PERIOD UP FOR CONSUMERS IN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET. AND OUR
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIOD RUNS
FROM FEBRUARY FIRST THROUGH THE
FIFTEEN. DURING THIS TIME MORE
INVESTING SIX MILLION TO RAISE
PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT THE
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIOD
INCLUDING WITH A DIGITAL AND
TELEVISION ADS. THAT STARTING
IN FEBRUARY. MELTER DISK SOME
OF DISCUSS AND PROPOSALS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL RELATED HEALTH
BENEFIT EXCHANGE'S AND HOW THEY
MIGHT IMPACT CALIFORNIA. I THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN THE
FEDERAL STIMULUS PROPOSAL UNDER
CONSIDERATION IN CONGRESS
INCLUDES SEVERAL PROVISIONS
THAT WOULD IMPACT EXCHANGES. OF
FIRST IT WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE PREMIUM SUPPORT FOR
INDIVIDUALS HELLO 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL OF FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO COVERAGE YEARS. IT
WOULD ALSO ELIMINATE THE
CURRENT FEDERAL CAP ON
SUBSIDIES FOR INDIVIDUALS OVER
4100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL AND ENSURE THAT NO ONE
WOULD HAVE TO PAY MORE THAN
EIGHT POINT 5% OF THEIR INCOME.
IN PREMIUMS FOR THE BENCHMARK
PLAN. THIS PROVISION WOULD ALSO
APPLY FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. FINALLY
THERE'S A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
MAKE RECIPIENTS OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. OFFERED THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA. SHOULD
THESE PROPOSALS THE ENACTED A
COVER CALIFORNIA WILL WORK WITH
THE AND- YOU KNOW ALLEGES TO
IMPLEMENT ANY NEEDED. WHAT WE
CAN SAY IS THAT THE FEDERAL
SUBSIDY STRUCTURE THAT'S
PROPOSED WOULD BE MORE GENEROUS
THAN THE STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE TODAY FOR INSTANCE
IN STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM L.
CONSUMERS PAY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
TEN AND 18% OF THEIR INCOME FOR
PREMIUMS IF THEY'RE IN OUR
410026100% OF GROUPS SO THIS
WOULD BE THE FEDERAL PROPOSAL
BE SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS. OF FOR
ALL ENROLLEES. IN OUR PROGRAM.
AND FINALLY A TO YOUR QUITE. OF
THE FEDERAL. WOULD PROVIDE
FORGET FOR. WHO HAVE TO WRITE.
AND RE. FEDERAL SUBSIDIES
PREMIUM SUBSIDY THAT RICK THEY
RECEIVE IN TWENTY TWENTY- ALL
CONSUMER AFTER. THEIR SUB. SOME
AT OUR GET A REFUND DURING
FILING PROCESS SOME OF CASES
PROPOSED. I WOULD FORGET THE
READ. THE COVER CALIFORNIA
PREMIUMS AND PRO ALL REQUIRE
RECKON. THROUGH THE FRANCHISE
BOARD ALSO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT CAL COULD CONSIDER.
HEARING FEDERAL POLICY. A DOZEN
END OF MY REMARKS I LOOK FOR TO
SPEAKING YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY. NEXT HAVE DIRECTOR LIBEL.
DR ON THE LOWER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON BOTH FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES- TO START ALL. WELL
SORT OF THE POPULATION
CALIFORNIA'S WORLD MEDICAL MORE
THAN HALF OF THE CHILDREN. GO
FOR THE COVERT UPDATE BEGAN WE
WERE ACTUALLY SINGLE DECLINE IN
THE MEDICAL CASE LONG MOMENTS
TWENTY SIXTEEN- HIGH POINT- THE
COMPANY WAS DOING STRONG ALL.
INCOMES WERE RISING AND WE WERE
SORT OF SEEING A MOVEMENT ALL
ALONG THE MEDICAL PROGRAM IN
TWO OR COVER CALIFORNIA'S
EXCHANGE- PROGRAMS- THE- PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY COURSE OF
COURSE BUT- WHERE WE HAD
REGIONALLY SPECIFIC BEING
HAVING A CASE BELOW THIRTEEN.
ALL IN THE CURRENT WE OF COURSE
WELL ON. ASCENTIAL THIRTEEN
ONLY AND CONTINUING TO RUN- THE-
THANK YOU ALMOST FOURTEEN WILL
EXCUSE ME ALL. IMPAR OF THIS
THE FIVE ABOUT WAS PART OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH MORE- WE SUSPEND
ALL READ IT NAY OF MEN CAL
ELIGIBILITY AND SO THAT MEANS
THAT. BY TIME THE ALL WORKING
SEE ANIMALS WHICH IS EXPRESS TO
BE DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY WE
WILL PASS TO SUBMIT TO CUBA.
ALL OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
PEOPLE A MONTH WHO WERE. FORMAL
COURSE OF EVENTS- HAVE- MORE
KNOWLEDGEABLE- THERE ARE FACT
OUT THERE MAY YET- CHANGE THE-
JEFF CURRY BILL ON BY DECEMBER
ALL. LABOR MARKET CAN AND WEBER
THERE'S STILL- RESIDUAL PARKING
MORE WE WILL NOT CAL SALT
FOLLOW ON THE LENGTH OF THAT
THEY OF THE WORK. ON SECOND IS
HOUSE THE R. VACCINE.
REALIZATION CAMPAIGN UP-
REMAINS AN END LOCAL PEOPLE
WHAT WAS TO RETURN TO. OUR
CLINICS HOW GENERAL MORE LONG
CALDERON CARE IN WHICH CASE
MAKE SURE INCREASE YOUR ROLE
WOES SO. NUMBER ONE ELEMENT IS
ONE WHAT ON LATE TO THE COME.
YOU MAY FIND THAT THERE IS A
PORTION OF CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE
WELL IT ROLLED OFF THE MACHINE.
BECAUSE OF. I'M GOING TO GO
CLIMATE SURROUNDING. I MEAN.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE WORLD. ASK
YOUR- I HAVE BEEN A SHIFTS AND
SQUADRONS BETWEEN- OF SPANISH
SPEAKING SEVERAL OF THE- LEAD
TO THANK THAT THERE MAY BE
POSSIBLE DOWNLOAD CRUSHER ON
ENROLLMENTS JUST OUT OF
CONCERN- WHERE FEDERAL POLICIES
DON'T SO THAT MAY- CLAY SOME-
WON'T HAVE SOME OF THAT
TOMORROW YEAH. THE NEW YORK- TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH
THE MEDICAL CREW. PART OF THE
THAT MAKE I'M GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO WELL J. C. COOPER. OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY JULY AND STAY
MEDICAID WHAT. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE. I'M SO I WILL SPEAK
TO- THE ACA AS OUR DURING THE
PUBLIC HELP THEM- I WILL COVER
A AREA OF WHERE EXPANDED.
DURING THE HEALTH AND THEN I
WILL QUICKLY TOUCH ON SOME
ADDITIONAL ITEMS FOR CASELOAD-
SO DO YOU SEE AS ACTED
IMMEDIATELY DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO REQUEST- OVER
SIXTY OR SEVENTY VARIOUS
POSSIBILITIES ACROSS VERY-
MULTIPLE. FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITIES- IT INCLUDED
THINGS LIKE PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION BILLING- AND
CONDITIONS FOR PAYMENT OF
FLEXIBILITIES AROUND STATE
THEIR HEARINGS ARE BENEFIT
FLEXIBILITIES INCLUDING AS A
TELEHEALTH EXPANSION WHICH WE
PREVIOUSLY PRESENTED TO THIS
GROUP- AS WELL AS ADJUSTMENTS
TO PAYMENTS- FOR THINGS LIKE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
TESTING. OXYGEN ARE VERY
CRITICAL ITEMS THAT WERE
NECESSARY DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND VARIOUS
ADMINISTRATIVE FLEXIBILITIES
ARE TO MEET THE NEEDS- OVER THE
GROWING MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC.
WE ALSO LAUNCHED A WEEKLY
STAKEHOLDER ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY PLANS AND OTHERS A
CONTRACT ALL THE VARIOUS
CHANGES IN THE PROGRAM DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY I
WOULD HAVE BEEN QUITE
EXPENSIVE. AND RELAUNCH THE
VARIOUS WEB PAGES SO THERE WAS
AN EASY WAY FOR PEOPLE TO GET
THAT INFORMATION OR TO STAY
CURRENT WITH THOSE
FLEXIBILITIES. THEY ALSO ISSUED
A BENEFICIARY NOTICE TO ALL
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES SO THEY
UNDERSTOOD THEIR RIGHTS DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE
FLEXIBILITIES THAT WERE BEING
ROLLED OUT TO THE INSURED THEY
KNEW HOW TO ACCESS CARE DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
SHE STAYS HEALTHY AS POSSIBLE
GIVEN OUR MANY OF THE OUR
PROVIDER OFFICES IN THE VERY
EARLY PART OF THE PANDEMIC HAD
ACTUALLY CLOSED OR RESTRICTED
ACCESS. WHICH WE SAW THE LARGE
INCREASE OF TELEHEALTH SERVICES
DURING THAT. TIME WE ALSO
LAUNCHED A MET A CAL NURSE LINE
WHICH PROVIDED TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN ACCESS TO ALL UNDER THE-
ENROLLED IN MEDICARE. ALSO IN
UNINSURED INDIVIDUALS ARE
THROUGH THAT TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
NURSE LINE WE ALSO INCLUDED
CONNECTING UNINSURED
INDIVIDUALS TO SEE IF THEY
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE
COVERAGE AS WELL AS IF THEY
WERE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE-
ARE UNINSURED COVERAGE GROUP. I
NOW KIND OF WALK THROUGH SOME
OF THE VARIOUS ELIGIBILITY
FLEXIBILITIES SPECIFICALLY THAT
WE ROLLED OUT DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AS BILL
MENTIONED. WE DO HAVE
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES SO.
ANY INDIVIDUAL ON THAT CAL WITH
VERY FEW EXCEPTIONS-
ESSENTIALLY OUR STATE HAS
STAYED ON DURING THE ENTIRE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND
WILL STATE ENROLLED IN MEDI CAL
AND HAVE COVERAGE UNTIL THE END
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
WHICH IS CURRENTLY PROJECTED TO
BE THROUGH THE END OF DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE ALSO
WAGE PREMIUMS AND COST SHARING
FOR CHIP BENEFICIARIES WE ADDED
THE OPTIONAL UNINSURED COVERAGE
NINETY- CODE NINETEEN
ELIGIBILITY GROUP. WHICH
INCLUDED TESTING AND- TESTING
RELATED SERVICES AND TREATMENT
OF FOR THOSE BENEFICIARIES TO
RECEIVE SERVICES DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. WE
EXPANDED HOSPITAL PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY TO INCLUDE OVER
SIXTY FIVE AGE AND DISABLED
POPULATION AS WELL AS ALLOWING
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE HOSPITAL
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY TO BE
COVERED MORE THAN ONE- H. P.
PERIOD IN A GIVEN TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD. ALSO THEY COULD NOW
HAVE TWO PERIODS WHEREAS
PREVIOUSLY IT WAS JUST ONE. WE
ISSUED GUIDANCE TO OUR COUNTIES
FOR HOW TO ENROLL WITHOUT AN
APPLICANT SIGNATURE AS WELL WAS
ROLLED OUT TELEPHONIC
ENROLLMENT IN OUR AFFECT
PROGRAM PROGRAM. AND EVERY
WOMAN COUNTS. KHAGANATE AS
INDEED. I'M HAS TO STICK IN ON
MEDICARE AND THE DEPARTMENTS
BUDGET- AS I WILL EXPLAIN
DURING HIS INTRODUCTION ON THE
MEDICARE CASELOAD HAS BEEN
DECLINING SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WE'RE WE DID HAVE A
PEEK AROUND THIRTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION SIMILAR TO THE NUMBER
OF LIVES. CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN
OUR PROGRAM TODAY- IN UP UNTIL
THAT POINT WE WERE SEEN THAT
DECLINE AND TELL THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY A HIT. WITH
THE CAN I WITH THE CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE OF REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND
OTHER CONSEQUENCES OF COURSE OF
THE- PANDEMIC. WE HAVE SEEN A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT INCREASE OF
CASELOAD- ON THE MEDICAL SIDE.
MEDI CAL I'M HAS REACHED AS
MENTIONED BEFORE THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN LEVELS OF
ACROSS ALL EIGHT CODES. IN OUR
LARGEST GROWTH SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN LEVELS IS IN
THE ACA OPTIONAL EXPANSION
WHERE IS PRIOR TO THAT IT HAD
BEEN PRETTY STEADY AND WE ARE
SEEING AN INCREASE. OF BASED ON
PREVIOUS LETTERS THAT WE LEVELS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN. I'M THE
CURRENT CASE LOAD UP. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS FOURTEEN
MILLION BNEFICIARIES. OUT
WHICH DOES INCLUDE A FOUR POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE OR
A ONE POINT SEVEN. MILLION
DOLLARS BILLION DOLLARS SORRY A
GENERAL FUND INCREASE IN IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THE CASE
LOAD IS PROJECTED AT FIFTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION
BENEFICIARIES. OF WHICH IS A
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE AND A THIRTY
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND INCREASE. OUR
COSTS RELATED TO THE CASE LOAD
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WERE-
BUILT OFF OF TRENDS FROM ABOUT
FOUR OR FIVE MONTHS- OF THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC OF
BUT THINGS HAVE. EVOLVED SINCE
THAT TIME AND WE HAVE A LOT
MORE DATA SO THE DEPARTMENT-
DOES CONTINUE TO LOOK AT MORE
RECENT DATA AND ACTUALS AND
WE'LL BE UPDATING OUR CODE
NINETEEN CASELOAD PROJECTIONS-
AFTER MAY REVISE TIME PERIOD.
I'M SO THAT IS THE CONCLUSION
OF OUR COMMENTS THANK YOU. NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM NED RESNICK
COUGH WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M GOING TO
SUMMARIZE SOME OF OUR FINDINGS
FROM OUR OFFICES ANALYSIS OF
THE MEDIC HOW BUDGET FOR THE
COMING YEAR- THE KEY PART OF
OUR ANALYSIS WAS FOCUSED ON
CASELOAD. BECAUSE CASELOAD
GROWTH ACCOUNTS FOR A
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF YOUR OVER
YOUR FUNDING EIGHT- IT IF YOUR
OF YOUR FUNDING INCREASE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OUT OF- FIVE
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE ABOUT TWO POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS AS RELATED TO
UNDERLYING CASE OF GROWTH. THE
KEY TAKE AWAY OF OUR ANALYSIS
IS WE THINK K. SO GROWTH WILL
BE LOWER THAN THE- INSPIRATION
PROJECTS AND IN FACT WE'RE
EXPECTING CATHOLIC RELATED
COSTS TO BE APPROXIMATELY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS LESS THAN IS
PROJECTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. BUT HAVING SAID
THAT WE ARE NOT RECOMMENDING
MAKING ANY ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
BUDGET RIGHT NOW I'D SAID WE
RECOMMEND WAITING FOR ME WHEN
WE SHOULD HAVE CONSIDERABLY
MORE DATA ABOUT KISSING GROWTH
OVER THAT THE COMING MONTHS TO.
MAKE A MAKE AN ASSESSMENT. OF
WHAT SHOULD BE GOING FORWARD.
THE REASON WHY WE THAT AT- KIDS
ARE GROWTH WILL BE LOWER AND
THEREFORE COST LESS A PRIMARILY
AS- WE THINK THAT IN ORDER FOR
K. SO GROWTH LEVELS- IN ORDER
FOR A- A CASELOAD GROWTH TO
REACH THE LEVELS PROJECTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. MONTHLY
CREASE CASELOAD GROWTH WE NEED
TO INCREASE BY NEARLY FIFTY
PERCENT- MORE THAN IT HAS ON
AVERAGE DURING THE PANDEMIC
THUS FAR FROM MARCH TO DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY- SO- FROM LESS
THAN A HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
NEW ENROLLEES PER MONTH WHICH
IS DIDN'T EAT THE AVERAGE AS
FAR WOULD HAVE TO INCREASE
UNTIL NEARLY TO NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND. WE FEEL LIKE
THAT'S THE- WITHIN THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY BUT IT'S LIKELY A
WORST CASE SCENARIO. I ALSO WE
THINK THAT- LESS OF THE GROWTH
WILL COME FROM- SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES THAT
IS PROJECTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION- BUT MORE
LIKELY. MORE OF THE GROWTH WILL
COME FROM FAMILIES AND CHILD
THIS ADULTS FROM THE ACA
OPTIONAL EXPANSION AND THOSE
POPULATIONS ARE TYPICALLY LESS
COSTLY TO COVER SO SAID THAT
ALSO ACCOUNTS FOR SOME OF THE
SAVINGS WE ANTICIPATE- BUT BUT
AGAIN. THESE PROJECTIONS ARE
SUBJECT TO UNCERTAINTY AND SO
WE ARE NOT RECOMMENDING ANY
ADJUSTMENTS AT THIS TIME UNTIL
MORE DATA IS AVAILABLE TO
REVIEW I THANK YOU AND I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THE
CONCLUSION OF THE PANEL I WILL
NOW BRING IT UP TO THE DíAS TO
SEE IF ANY MEMBERS. HAVE
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE I WILL
BEGIN MY FIRST QUESTION WILL BE
FOR THE STAKEHOLDERS BOTH JOSE
TORE AS AN ORACLE THOMAS. I
WANTED YOU TO HELP FRAME IT FOR
US- YOUR EXPERIENCE WORKING
WITH THE UNINSURED POPULATION.
HOW ARE THESE POPULATIONS
AFFECTED BY THE LACK OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND HOW ARE ALL OF
US AFFECTED BY MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS LACKING ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. HI THIS IS A
HORRIBLE THOMAS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY CENTER I'LL
GO FIRST. AND YOU KNOW TO HOW
THE POPULATION IS AFFECTED BY A
LACK OF ACCESS TO HEALTH ARE I
THINK WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST
YEAR WHAT HAPPENS WITH COBIT
AND FOR THOSE POPULATIONS THAT
DO NOT UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW
THEIR PRIOR CONDITIONS OR THEIR
HEALTH- BEING ADVERSELY
AFFECTED BY THE COMORBIDITIES
AND SO IF THEY HAD ACCESS OVER
THE YEARS TO PREVENTATIVE CARE
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THEIR NEEDS AND TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND ACCORDINGLY IN THE
MIDST OF A GLOBAL HEALTH
PANDEMIC WHETHER THAT IS.
TAKING TIME AWAY FROM LIFE
THREATENING WORK OR TRYING TO
ENFORCE AND TO GET MORE
PRECAUTIONS- FOR CONDITIONS
THAT THEY KNOW PUT THEM AT
GREATER RISK WHEN IT COMES TO
THE GREATER POPULATION I THINK.
WE COULD SAY THAT THE COST OF
CARE. FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS DOES
GO UP WHEN WE SEE THAT A LACK
OF ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE CARE.
AND CLINIC VISITS. WOULD RESULT
IN GREATER- YOU KNOW TRIPS TO
EMERGENCY ROOM FOR CARE THAT
MIGHT BE MORE EXPENSIVE BECAUSE
IT HAS TO DEAL WITH LARGER
CHRONIC CONDITIONS THAT ARE
MORE ADVANCED STAGES- WHETHER
THESE ARE THINGS LIKE- LIKE
THREATENING ILLNESSES SUCH AS
CANCER TO DEEPER STAGE. OR
THINGS THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED- WHETHER IT IS-
ADVERSE HEALTH REACTIONS THAT
HAPPEN WITH WORKFORCE OR
WORKING CONDITIONS. THOSE ARE A
COUPLE THAT I COULD THINK UP
THE TOP OF MY HEAD I'LL- PASS
IT ALONG TO MY PARTNER JOSE FOR
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS. YES
OF COURSE THANK YOU R. O. N. TO
ADD ON TO WHAT I HAVE A PARTNER
OR JUST MENTION. THERE THE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION DOES
NOT HAVE ANY ACCESS TO PREVENT
OR PRIMARY CARE SO WHEN DAISY
HOW. ISSUE CRIME CONDITIONS
SUCH AS DIABETES- DIABETES
HEART DISEASE OR CANCER THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO GET IT TAKEN CARE
OF AS IT AS IT SHOULD BE- FOR
VARIOUS DISEASES THEY MIGHT USE
THE EMERGENCY CARE BUT THEY
CAN'T SEE. LONG TERM CARE AND-
AT THE EMERGENCY ROOM SAME WITH
IF THEY WORK IF THEY CONTRACT
HOPE IT. UNDER THE UNDER THE
CAR UNDER THE CURRENT STATUS
THEY'RE ABLE TO GET ANYTHING
THAT ANY MEDICAL CARE RELATED
TO KOBE IT BY THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO ADDRESS ANY OTHER UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS SO. AN OVERALL. IT'S
JUST THESE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
SUFFERING FROM THIS LACK OF
ACCESS AND IT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL IN THE LONG TERM.
WHERE WE- AN OFFICIAL LONG TERM
WEAR DRESSING THESE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS NOW WHAT STATE WOULD
GO ON AND SAVE A STATE HEALTH
CARE. COSTS IN THE FUTURE AS
WELL. WITHOUT FRAMING I'D LIKE
TO NOW TURN MY QUESTIONS TO THE
LAUREL LUCIA AND I'M LOOKING AT
PAGE SEVEN OF YOUR PRESENTATION
HERE TODAY. AND REALLY LOOKING
OUT THE PERCENT OF LATINOS
COVERED CASES AND DEATHS
COMPARED WITH THE PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULATION. AND WHAT'S
STRIKING TO ME ARE ARE A NUMBER
OF THINGS FIRST IS THAT THE
LATINO POPULATION WHILE THIRTY
EIGHT POINT 9% OF THE OVERALL
CALIFORNIA. WE ONLY REPRESENT
21% OF THOSE WHO ARE AGES SIXTY
FIVE TO SEVENTY NINE. IS THAT
BECAUSE OF OUR UNDERLYING
HEALTH DISPARITIES IS THAT
BECAUSE OF OUR LACK OF.
PREVENTIVE HEALTH CARE ACCESS
ARE YOU ABLE TO COMMENT ON WHY
THERE'S SUCH A DISCREPANCY- IN
THAT FIGURE. SURE EIGHT YEAH D.
B. DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE PRESS
AND A PUBLIC CASES THAT ARE
AMONG LATINOS AND THEIR SHARE
POPULATION IS A- IT IS SEVERE
ENOUGH ACROSS ALL AGES BUT
PARTICULARLY AMONG THOSE WHO
ARE SIXTY FIVE TO SEVENTY NINE.
AND A- I THINK A LACK OF HEALTH
INSURANCE IS ONE DRIVER OF THE
OF THE TRANS RESTING HERE IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT THE SOLE DRIVER
OCCUPATIONAL RISKS ARE ANOTHER
DRIVER- HOW DID HOUSING AND IS
ANOTHER RISK FACTOR FOR CO
THAT- ED THERE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FACTORS
THAT UNDERLIE THIS BUT BUT
HEALTH INSURANCE IS ONE OF
THEM. AND THEN THE MECHANISM BY
WHICH HEALTH INSURANCE COULD
AFFECT COULD. SPREAD AND COPE
WITH THE DEATH RATES AS IS THAT
WE KNOW FROM PREVIOUS RESEARCH
THAT WHEN PEOPLE HAVE INSURANCE
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO GET THE
CARE THEY NEED. AND IN THAT
CASE A COVETED THAT'S COULD BE
TESTING OR- FOR PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY FEEL SICK WITH KOBE- IN
GETTING THE CARE THEY NEED
BEFORE IT'S TOO LATE AND- WHEN
PEOPLE. ARE HESITANT TO GET
TESTING BECAUSE. OF COST A- YOU
KNOW THEY- END UP AS A
SPREADING IN THE AFFECTS ALL OF
US AND- I HOPE THAT ADDRESSES
THE QUESTION. IT'S CLOSE BUT I
REALLY WANT TO DIG IN HERE A
LITTLE BIT IT SEEMS THAT WE
HAVE A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
COMBAT DEATHS FOR LATINO
SENIORS AND- MY QUESTION IS
THAT BECAUSE OF THE UNDERLYING
HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT LACK OF
PREVENTIVE CARE IS IT THAT.
THEY HAVE UNTREATED DIABETES
AND HYPERTENSION AND THAT WHEN
THEY THEN GET COVE AND THEY
HAVE A TENDENCY TO GET SICKER
AND DIE SOONER IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE SEEING BORN OUT IN THE
STATE IS THAT- A TREND
CONSISTENT. I THINK THAT. WHAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING IS DEFINITELY
AN IMPORTANT FACTOR- A. EIGHT.
D. A. I THINK A LOT MORE
RESEARCH WOULD HAVE TOBE DONE
SAID J. IDENTIFIED LIKE HOW
EXACTLY HOW MUCH. THE LACK OF
HEALTH INSURANCE IS DRIVING
THESE. DISPARITIES BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY AN IMPORTANT FACTOR.
LET ME TRY AND APPROACH THE
QUESTION AND FROM A DIFFERENT
AND AN ECONOMIC WAY IF I CAN-
DOES IT COST CALIFORNIA MORE OR
LESS TO MAKE THE UP FRONT
INVESTMENT IN EXPANDING
INSURANCE COVERAGE TO PEOPLE.
AS AN EXAMPLE DOES THE UP FRONT
INVESTMENT RESULT IN SAVINGS IN
THE LONG RUN WHAT IT. MAKES
SENSE FOR US TO BE INVESTING IN
PREVENTATIVE CARE SO WE DON'T
HAVE THEIR UNDERLYING DIABETES
AND HYPERTENSION THE OUT OF
CONTROL AND HAVE THESE.
OUTCOMES AND DISPARITIES THAT
WE'RE SEEING. I THINK THE BEST
RESULTS YEAR EXPANDS MEDICAL
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS IS THAT IT WILL IMPROVE
PEOPLE'S ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE-
AND THEREFORE IMPROVE THEIR
HEALTH OUTCOMES. A IT WILL
REQUIRE SOME STATE INVESTMENTS
BECAUSE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE THEY USE MORE CARE-
AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOAL WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE. WHICH IS AS
REDUCING BARRIERS TO CARE BASED
ON ON COSTS AND INSURANCE
STATUS I AM. THERE IS CERTAINLY
ARE ARE CASES WHERE- IT. HEALTH
EXPENDITURES WILL BE LOWER WHEN
YOU GET THE PREVENTATIVE CARE
YOU NEED BUT THERE ARE ALSO
CASES WHERE- HEALTHCARE
EXPENDITURES COULD BE HIGHER
BUT THE OUTCOMES ARE BETTER.
LOOK AT THE CANCER SCREENING
THEY NEED AT THE RIGHT TIME- IT
MAY IDENTIFY MORE CANCER CASES
BUT WE'LL SEE PEOPLE LIVING
LONGER HEALTHIER LIVES WHICH IS
ULTIMATELY THE CALL. AND I ALSO
AM. SEE THISAS A INVESTMENT
AND REDUCING INEQUITY IN THE
STATE- THE BIGGEST GROUPS OF
UNINSURED. BY ELIGIBILITY
STATUS OF COURSE AS I SAID IN
MY PRESENTATION ARE
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS BUT
WHEN WE COME AS- A CALIFORNIANS
ARE. ANOTHER BIG GROUP OF
UNINSURED AS ARE LATINO
CALIFORNIANS AND SO- EXPANDING
MEDIC HOW WOULD TAKE SOME STATE
INVESTMENT BUT IT WOULD BE- AND
INVESTMENT INDIVIDUALS WHO
CURRENTLY LACK COVERAGE TODAY
WHICH HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
BENEFITS US ALL AND IT WOULD
ALSO BE AN INVESTMENT. IN
REDUCING INEQUITIES. IF I COULD
BRING YOU BACK TO THIS. THAN I
WAS HOPING THAT- YOU CAN
SPECIFICALLY TALK ABOUT HOW YOU
ARE RECOMMENDING TO TAKE STEPS
TOWARDS UNIVERSAL COVERAGE. ARE
YOU RECOMMENDING A PHASED IN
APPROACH STARTING WITH SENIORS
THIS YEAR AND IF SO WHAT WOULD
BE THE NEXT PHASES. THANK YOU
AT CHAIR AROUND OF THAT
QUESTION I THINK WE HAVE LOOKED
AT SENIORS BEING THE DOWN
PAYMENT AND THAT YOU'VE
DESCRIBED THAT SEVERAL TIMES
OVER THIS YEAR. I AND AS FAR AS
WHERE THE NEXT STEPS GO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO FOCUS ON WITH OUR COMMUNITY
AND SEE WHERE THEIR HEADS ARE
AT AND WHERE THEY THINK IS THE
BEST QUALITIES POLICY DECISION.
FOR THE AND DOCUMENTED
POPULATION. IF I COULD I NOW
WANT TO BRING IT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TO- DIRECTOR
LIGHT BORN AND- HI I WAS STRUCK
DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN THAT THIS
IS THE LARGEST ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAM WE HAVE AND- I THINK
THAT'S A POWERFUL STATEMENT
ANYONE AYE- THINK IS IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU REPRESENT UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY LIKE MINE WHO YOU
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET FOR US TO
EFFECTIVELY WORK ON ANTI
POVERTY PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALSO
HELPING ARE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY MATTERS FOR MANY OF
US HERE ON THE DYESS. BUT I
WANTED TO TALK IF I COULD ABOUT
THE ECONOMICS OF OUR STATE A
LITTLE BIT WE'RE NOT BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE AND WANTED TO TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE CASELOAD
NUMBER BECAUSE IT SEEMS THAT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN OUR CURRENT
CASELOAD AND THE PROJECTIONS
THAT WE ARE TO GROW INTO AND-
I. WONDERING IF YOU CAN COMMENT
ON WHERE THOSE SAVINGS WILL BE
GOING AND WHETHER THEY COULD BE
RE DIRECTED TOWARDS HELPING TO
ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES WE SAW
DURING THE PANDEMIC- YOU TAKE A
SHOT OF. ALONG WITH- ALL FIRST
HOUSE. J. C. MENTIONED NO
MENTION- WE WILL BE A- AT THE
MAYOR OF THOSE WILL BE LOOKING
OLD TRIANGLE. ALL A SUDDEN IN
MY REMOTE WERE BROUGHT OF.
DRIVERS IMPACT THAT YEP WHY I
REMAIN ON. WELL I'M- TURNING TO
THE CORE ARE WHERE WE'RE GO- IF
ABOUT. YOUR THINGS TO SAID
ABOUT AND X. LITTLE IN ANYWAY
BECAUSE THAT I THINK IS THERE
IS NOW SEEMS TO ME SORT OF A
HUMAN APPRECIATE. OF THE NEED
FOR HEALTH COVERAGE PEOPLE ALL
WAS WELL BEFORE IT'S NOT IN NOW.
WELL AND DOZENS NISMAN'S TWO
ARE BROKEN. ALL ON ENSURE
POPULATION INCOME LARGISH BURKE
OF THE CORNER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON. WHAT I THINK IS OUR SHARED
FOLDER WITH DESIRE OF UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE ALL. SO LET ME STOP.
I'M ONE OF THOSE LINES THEN I
WON'T SLOWLY GO AND LOOK AT
CASELOAD GROWTH I WILL ALSO
IDENTIFY THAT- MISS ROUTE REVAL
FROM- SHOULD COVER CALIFORNIA
TALKED ABOUT SAVINGS FROM THE
FEDERAL SUPPORT AND 410026100%
AS WELL AS THE INCREASED F. MAP
THAT WE RECEIVED FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AS WELL AS THE
WINDFALL THAT OUR STATE IS
GOING THROUGH THERE ARE
MULTIPLE AVENUES FOR US TO HAVE
A PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION THAT
THAT I THINK THE QUESTION FOR
MANY OF US IS WHEN. WE'RE
PUSHING AND MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION- WHEN CAN WE EXPECT
TO GET TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
WHEN I OPENED. AGAIN I DON'T
WANT TO STOPPABLE BY LANE ALL
THE CLEARLY THOSE ARE STILL THE
DIALOGUE BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE LEADERSHIP. SPOKE
FROM THE B. WHILE BE HAPPY
EARLY THAT LOS OUR COUNTY ALL.
TO GET YOU KNOW TO THAT PLACE
SOME POINT WHERE WE CAN SEE WE
HAVE YOU. YOU WALK THROUGH WHAT
CALL MEANS THE THAT SEEKS. I
THINK I HEAR YOU LIGHT AND-
HAPPY FOR ALL OF US TO THE STAY
WITH OUR OWN LANE- DO THINK I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE UP THE
URGENCY THAT MANY OF US ARE
FEELING FROM THIS PANDEMIC WE-
OUR HOME AND- HEAR LOUDLY FROM
OUR COMMUNITIES THE STRUGGLE
THAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
RIGHT NOW AND- REALLY BELIEVE-
THE WORK THAT WE ARE DOING.
TOGETHER AND COLLABORATIVE LEE
IS IMPORTANT AND- MOVES OUR
STATE FORWARD AND ULTIMATELY IT
IS- HOW WE TAKE CARE OF THOSE
WHO ARE VULNERABLE AND HAVE
NEEDS RIGHT NOW THAT ALL OF US
WILL BE REMEMBERED AND- DO YOU
WANT TO. THANKS A LOT I THINK
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BOTH HERE.
WELL I STILL- I'VE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE
DIRECTOR AND TO AS WELL AS YOUR
CANDOR DURING THIS DISCUSSION.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD PANEL
ONE OPEN AND MOVE ON THE PANEL
TO. STERLITE BORN YOU HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF LEADING OFF PANEL
TO. YES ALONG WE SENT TO
MATURITY WELL. THE PANEL
COURSES REGARDING OUR PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL TO- ALL. PENALTIES
FOR IMPROPER DISCHARGES- LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES- THE
BACKGROUND HERE IS CLEARLY WE
RECOGNIZE THE ISSUE RESOLVED
ALL SO THE TRANSFERS DISCHARGES
READMISSIONS CAN BE A VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE- BUT
RESIDENTS IN THESE FACILITIES
AND DEVELOP VERY VULNERABLE-
ALONG AND THEIR CARE CAN BE
CHALLENGING AND FACILITIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WOULD DEPEND ON.
SERVICES POURTANT INSTEAD QUOTE.
FEDERAL MEDICAID LAW
STIPULATES- THE SINGLE STATE
AGENCY JUST YET COS IS REQUIRED
TO CONDUCT THEIR HEARINGS OR
RESIDENTS WHO BELIEVE. OFTEN
TRANSFERRED JUST DISCHARGED OR
REFUSE NATIONAL USUALLY FROM OF
ALL HOSPITALS- AND THE HEARINGS
ARE TO PROVIDE YOU CROSS BOTH
THE RESIDENT I AM FROM THE
FACILITIES- TO MAKE THE CASE OF
THE FULFILL RESPONSIBILITIES.
WE CURRENTLY CONDUCT A COUPLE
HUNDRED OF THESE HEARINGS
ANNUAL MOST OF WHICH ARE
DECIDED IN FAVOR OF THE
RESIDENT. ALL JUST TO BE CLEAR
THERE ARE LEGALLY PERMISSIBLE
REASONS ON. THE LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY CAN DISCHARGE HOME A
RESIDENT- CENTRALLY. ALL
RESIDENTS NEEDS CAN'T BE MET
ASSEMBLY. HOWEVER THE FACILITY
IS RESPONSIBLE. THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR DISCHARGE
PLANNING TO OCCUR. ONE IS WHERE
THE PRESIDENT WILL NOW SAY R.
O. THERE IS LOCAL CALLED
SOMEWHERE ELSE- HOME SO THIS
HOSPITAL CONSCIOUSLY BROWN.
ARTICOLI WE RECEIVED COMPLAINTS
ALL- ABOUT HOME FAILURE
FACILITIES TO COMPLY WITH OUR
HEARING DECISION- AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO ENFORCEABLE-
AUTHORITY TO RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY ALL OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS. BE COMPOSED
CURRENTLY BILL SEEKS TO REMEDY
THAT WELCOME. CONTINUE TO SORT
OF WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS BOTH
WARM CAMERON TRIAL. SPACE
AROUND WHAT- IT'S SOMETHING WE-
ALL- IN TERMS OF QUESTIONS
WHICH BARS- WE CAN ACCOUNT FROM
AND SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN. WELL
BOROUGH. HE DID NOT OWN-
ACTIONAL BEHALF OF THE DISPOSE.
AND WE ONLY KNOW THOSE
CURRENTLY IF IS INFORMATION IS
BROUGHT BACK SO THAT MAYBE MORE
OPEN. SURE BUT CERTAIN. TO-
CHECK THE NUMBER BHOSLE IS
STRUGGLING TO- AND SO OF LAWS
THE SOLDIER BEHAVE IT'S NOT.
CREATE A REVENUE STREAM ALL WE
WOULD BE MORE. HAPPY IF- AS A
OF WE NEVER HAD THE OPERATOR TO
ALONG COLLEGE. OR MMHM. BUT THE
PROCESS WITH- HE HEARING IS
GOING TO BY A LONG TERM WILL
TRAIN THE HEARING- RESIDENT AND
LOCAL SO THE ALL CAN INTRODUCE
EVIDENCE BEFORE CUSTOMER
EXAMINING CROSS EXAMINE
WITNESSES- IN ORDER TO AVAIL
THE FACILITY MUST SHOW THAT
THE- FOLLOWING FEDERAL LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS. TO DISCHARGE
RESIDENT. THERE'S A LEGAL
REASON REASON FOR CRIMES
DOCUMENTS. RESIDENTS MEDICAL
WORKERS THE FACILITY UNDER WILL
DISCHARGE PLANNING TO ENSURE
CYNICAL FORMALLY DISCHARGED.
SHORTLY PROVIDED WRITTEN NOTICE
OF TRANSFER AND DISCHARGE ALL
RECORD CONTENT INCLUDING
BOOSTING THE LOCATION TO WHICH.
IS BEING DESTROYED- RESIDENTS
TYPICALLY WORK THEMSELVES THIS
YEAR OKAY EARLY FAMILY MEMBER.
OR TABLET WILL BE- PERSONAL
TYPICALLY WORK WAS SO WITH
THEIR OWN. ASIAN WITH TURNS OUT
MOST RECENTLY- BY PHONE- SHOWS.
B. HEARINGS- WE'RE ARE REQUIRED
BY FEDERAL STATE MORE ON NOT
THIS AS FORMAL. WHICH ARE COULD
NOT. WHERE ONE OF THE JUDGES
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ON
BECAUSE OF WE ALL THIS FOR A
LONG TIME MAINTENANCE- IN ORDER.
TO SURE DANGER A VERY. IN REAL
TIME SO WITH THAT BUT WILL TOOK
AND ARE PRO. WEST NEXT ON MY
LIST OF PRESENTERS I JC FOLLOW
BY AMY BLOOM BURKE. I DON'T
THINK J. C. ACTING US ALMOST.
GENERAL AND- AT MAXWELL AMY
BLOOMBERG. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANY BLOOMBERG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES
REPRESENTING OVER NINE HUNDRED
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES.
SERVING PERSONS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. CAMPUS
OPPOSED TO DH CS IS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL THAT WILL PLACE
NEW ADDITIONAL FINES ON
FACILITIES THAT DO NOT COMPLY
WITH TRANSFER OR DISCHARGE
HEARING DECISIONS. CALF AS
OPPOSED FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS NUMBER ONE TRANSPORTERS
ARE CHALLENGING AND COMPLEX
ISSUE AS HAS BEEN STATED
ALREADY THESE HAPPEN VERY
RARELY AND ARE OFTEN DONE
BECAUSE A PATIENT POSES A
SAFETY RISK TO OTHER RESIDENTS
AND STAFF. FACILITIES HAD VERY
FEW TOOLS TO ADDRESS RESIDENTS
WHO ARE VIOLENT AND CHILLS AT
RISK. NUMBER TWO THE CURRENT
HEARING PROCESS IS BROKEN AND A
NICE TO PROCESS TO FACILITIES
HEARING OFFICERS AT THESE
INFORMAL HEARINGS NOT
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
THE UNDERLYING REASON WHY
FACILITY IS SEKING TO TRANSFER
OR DISCHARGE A PATIENT IS NOT
CONSIDERED. ONLY WHETHER A
FACILITY HAS FOLLOWED THE
APPROPRIATE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES IS REVIEWED IN ORDER
TO MAKE THIS PROCESS MORE FAIR
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES
SHOULD OVERSEE THESE HEARINGS
AND THE REASON FOR THE JUST
CHARGE THE COR SUBSTANTIVE
ISSUES REQUIRED UNDER THE
FEDERAL DOUBLE FEDERAL.
REGULATIONS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED. PENALTIES THE EIGHT
S. C. M. S. RT THE TO SIGN
FACILITY FOR PHILLY TO WITH
TRANSFERRED TO CHARGE HEARING
DECISIONS THIS PROPOSAL AS A
NAIL FINE AGAINST FACILITIES
THAT IS TWENTY TIMES THE
CURRENT FINE ASSESSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE ALREADY PROVIDES
FOR A FIFTY DOLLAR PER DAY FINE
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUIRES THE FACILITIES
AT TAKE THEIR RESIDENT BACK IN
ORDER TO SUBMIT A PROPOSAL PLAN
OF CORRECTION AND THE FACILITY
REFUSES TO DO SO ALSO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH CAN
ISSUE A BI LEVEL CITATION UNDER
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR ET. AND FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE EIGHT
FOUR WITH A MAXIMUM PENALTY OF
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IF
APPROPRIATE. CAN QUESTIONS THAN
FOR G. TO IMPOSE ADDITIONAL I
PENALTY. AND ESPECIALLY A
THOUSAND PER DAY WHICH IS
TWENTY TIMES HIGHER THAN THE
CURRENT PENALTY. NUMBER FOUR WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A POLICY ISSUE
THAT SHOULD BE DECIDED AND
POLICY COMMITTEE AND NOT IN A
TRAILER AND A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. IN TERMS OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT I'VE BEEN ASKED. TO
DESCRIBE THE MOST COMMON
SITUATIONS THAT CAUSE
FACILITIES TO VIOLATE TO DH CS
ORDERS TO ADMIT OUR READMIT
PATIENTS THESE SITUATIONS
HAPPEN VERY RARELY MOST COMMON
SITUATIONS ARE WHEN A RESIDENT
MAY HAVE A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUE AND ESTHER AND TWO OR
HARM TO ANOTHER RESIDENT OR
STAFF MEMBER. OTHER SITUATIONS
ARE WHEN A RESIDENT NO LONGER
NEED SKILLED NURSING CARE BUT
REFUSES TO LEAVE THE FACILITY
THERE ARE SOME RESIDENTS THAT
DISAGREE WITH THE NOTICE OF
JUST CHARGE THEY RECEIVE THAT
MAY BE RELATED TO FAILURE TO
PAY FOR CARE OR NO LONGER
REQUIRING THE LEVEL OF CARE.
PHYSICIAN MUST CERTIFY FOR. THE
SECOND. DESCRIBE WAYS IN WHICH
THE HEARING PROCESS AT DH CS
COULD BE CHANGED. AS I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WE'D LIKE
TO SEE AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE OVERSEE A FORMAL TRANSFER
DISCHARGE HEARING. AND ADDITION
THE RATIONALE FOR WHY THEIR
RESIDENT IS BEING TRANSFERRED
OR DISCHARGED WITH THE COURSE
SUBSTANTIVE ISSUES- UNDER THE
APPLICABLE FEDERAL REGULATION
LIKE TO SEE THOSE CONSIDERED.
NOT JUST WHETHER AT THE
FACILITY HAS COMPLETED THE
APPROPRIATE KEEPER BURKE. AND
NUMBER THREE WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS PATIENT SOMETHING THAT
GOES ON- AND THE SKILLED
NURSING PROFESSION THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED. NO THERE'S NOT
AN ISSUE OF PATIENT DUMPING
THERE ARE SOME RESIDENTS THAT
DISAGREE WITH THE NOTICE OF
JUST CHARGE AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY. THAT THEY RECEIVE
THAT MAY BE RELATED TO FAILURE
TO PAY FOR CARE OR NO LONGER
REQUIRING THE LEVEL OF CARE
THAT A PHYSICIAN MUST CERTIFY
FOR. WE BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AS THE LACK OF CARE
AND SERVICES TO SUPPORT THOSE
WITH DEMENTIA AND OTHER
NEUROBEHAVIORAL DISORDERS THAT
RESULTS AND AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIORS TOWARDS OTHER
RESIDENTS AND THE VERY STAFF
THEY'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE CARE.
ALSO WHAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
AS THE LACK OF HOUSING FOR
TRANSIENT INDIVIDUALS THAT
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
ACCEPT AN ORDER SIX LAST ASSIST
HOSPITALS. FOR SHORT TERM CARE
AND THERE NOT BEING ANY SAFE
PLACE TO DISCARGE THEM FALLING
TREATMENTS AND THEY'RE LEFT
WITHOUT AN APPROPRIATE. CHARGE
OF LOCATION. WE HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WHICH WE-
APPRECIATED AND HOPE TO
CONTINUE. TO WORK ON THIS. HAVE
A PROCEED AT THE CONVERSATION
THUS FAR. THANK YOU WITHOUT A
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE DíAS
AND SEE IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUNS
THANK YOU UP MISTER CHAIR- AND
FOR AMY AND HER- DISCUSSION
JUST A FOLLOW UP ON THE- LACK
OF HOUSING TO START DISCHARGE.
OF PATIENTS TO IS THAT. ALSO A
CAUSE FOR- BACKING UP THE BED
SPACE OR SPACE- WITHIN THE
HOSPITAL'S ITSELF BECAUSE OF.
NOT BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT
HOUSING EXTERNALLY. YES I
BELIEVE THAT'S ALL THE. WITHOUT
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL TO WE WILL MOVE ON THE
PANEL THREE ON SUSPENSIONS OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX PAYMENTS
AND MEDICARE ALL OPTIONAL
BENEFITS WE HAVE THREE
PRESENTERS DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN
J. C. COOPER AND COREY HARSHA
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. DIRECTOR ALLY BORN
PLEASE BEGIN. WE CORRECT GEN
LISTICLE BURKE. SO CURRENT LAW
CURRENTLY PROVIDES FOR THE
SUSPENSION OF A NUMBER OF PROP
FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND A
NUMBER OF OPTIONAL BENEFITS AT
THE END OF DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET GENERALLY- PROPOSES TO
DELAY THOSE SUSPENSION DATES BY
ONE YEAR SAW WALK THROUGH THE
CURRENT PROPOSED SAYS THAT- NEW
DATES OF JULY OF TWENTY TWO OR
POSITIONS DENTAL NONEMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION TRAUMA
SCREENINGS DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS AND VALUE BASED
PAYMENTS. OZ'S NEW SUSPENSION
DATE OF DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOR ICF D.'S FREE
STANDING PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
AND R. C. BASS ITEMS. THERE'S
NO PROPOSED SUSPENSION FOR
WOMEN'S HEALTH FAMILY PLANNING
LOAN REPAYMENTS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INCENTIVE OF COOL. BUT
AIDS HIV WAIVER HOME HEALTH AND
PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH CARE- ALSO
WOULD KNOW THAT THE POST PARTUM
ELIGIBILITY- EXTENSION IS
THROUGH DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWO.
AT ALL OPTIONAL BENEFITS
THROUGH DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWO
INCLUDING AUDIOLOGY AND SPEECH
THERAPY- AND OTHER ODD OPTIONAL
BENEFITS PROVISIONAL POSTPARTUM
CARE EXTENSION- IN WOULD NOTE
THAT THE EXPANSION OF SCREENING
FOR ADDITIONAL SUBSTANCES ALSO
KNOWN AS EXPERT. I'M HAS BEEN
MOVED TO A PREVENTATIVE SERVICE
UNDER FEDERAL LAW AND THEREFORE
REQUIRED TO COVER. IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. REGARDING ANY
RATIONALE JUSTIFICATION FOR
HAVING THE SUSPENSIONS- IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET YOU WILL- DEFER
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
REGARDS TO THAT QUESTION THIS
CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS. NEXT WE
HAVE HARSH ENOUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK AFTER ARAMBULA KOREAN
SHEET WITH THE AUDIO- AS AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA FOR THIS
HEARING OUR OFFICES PUBLISHED
ANALYSIS- DISCUSSING THE
SUSPENSIONS ACROSS THE BUDGET
GENERALLY- NOT JUST NOT JUST
ENGAGE THE ASTON AND MEDICARE
BUT ACROSS ACROSS THE BUDGET-
IN WHICH WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CREATE
NEW BUDGET BILL SUSPENSION
<c.magenta>ANGUAGE- JUST TO SUM UP OUR</c>
FINDINGS FROM OUR OUR OUR POST
WE FIND THAT MOST OF THE
SUSPENSION ITEMS. FUNDED CORE
STATE SERVICES THAT SHOULD BE
TREATED AS ONGOING COSTS- AND
NOT AS TEMPORARY COST AS THE
SUSPENSION MECHANISM MAKES THEM.
WE ALSO FIND THAT- THE
SUSPENSIONS CREATE UNCERTAINTY
FOR PROVIDERS AND RECIPIENTS OF
SERVICES FOR THE PROGRAMS-
POTENTIALLY AFFECTED BY THE
SUSPENSIONS- WHICH COULD SORT
OF HAVE NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON ON
SERVICE DELIVERY- WE WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT ARE OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE SUSPENSIONS ARE WITH
THE MECHANISM OF. SUSPENSION
SPECIFICALLY- MEANING THAT OUR
OUR RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT A
NEW SUSPENSION LANGUAGE DOESN'T
PRECLUDE THE STATE FROM
ASSESSING WHICH SUSPENSION ITEM
SHOULD CONTINUE GOING FORWARD-
YOU KNOW WE SORT OF A DREAM-
YOU KNOW IN OUR IN OUR POST WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. THE REALITIES
OF SORT OF THE MULTI YEAR-
CHALLENGES THAT THE STATE WILL
FACE WITH HIS FISCAL SITUATION
AND- WE VIEW THAT- WE'VE YOU
ADDRESSING THE YOU KNOW THE
STATE'S. FISCAL FUTURE IN THE
MULTI YEAR AS SOMETHING THAT
CAN ASSIST THEM THAT CAN OCCUR
SEPARATELY- FROM THAT FROM THE
SUSPENSION MECHANISM
SPECIFICALLY WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT THAT WE RAISE ISSUES WITH-
THAT SORT OF CONCLUDES OUR OUR
OFFICES. THANK VERY MUCH
MEMBERS AND QUESTIONS. SEEING
NONE I DO HAVE WHAT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- JC COOPER I WANT TO
GET A SENSE OF FIGHT COULD
ABOUT WITH THE SUSPENSIONS
WHETHER OR NOT YOU BELIEVE THAT
PROP FIFTY SIX REACHES ITS FULL
POTENTIAL IN TERMS OF
ATTRACTING AND RETAINING
PROVIDERS INTO THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. COULD WE DO BETTER
WITH MORE CERTAIN LONG TERM
PROVIDER RATES AND SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS. WELL WHAT I WOULD SAY
IS THAT- YOU KNOW MEDIC
CALIFORNIANS THING IS VERY
COMPLICATED- WE HAVE A BASE
RATES- AND THEN WE HAVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF. A BOTH SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS AS WELL AS DIRECTED
PAYMENTS ARM AND VARIOUS-
MECHANISMS IN WHICH AND HOW WE
PAY FOR OUR DELIVERY SYSTEM-
AND SO I THINK WE ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING TO EVALUATE HOW WE CAN
ENSURE WE HAVE. A NETWORK
ADEQUACY FOR ALL OF OUR
BENEFITS YEARS IN REGARDS TO
APPROPRIATE ACCESS TO BOTH
PROVIDERS OF DENTAL SERVICES AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE OTHER
CRITICAL SERVICES THAT- ARE
RECEIVING SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
FROM PROP FIFTY SIX. I THINK
THAT'S WHY YOU DIDN'T SEE-
CERTAIN PIECES- BEING
HIGHLIGHTED ADDS NOT SUBJECT TO
SUSPENSION AND OR AREAS WHERE
WE DON'T EEN FEEL LIKE CMS
WOULD ALLW FOR- THE TRANSITION
OUT OF SUCH POP- YOU KNOW
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS BECAUSE
OF HOW CRITICAL THEY ARE. WE
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE OF ALL
PROPERTY SIX PIECES AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. AS WE CONTINUE
THOSE EVALUATIONS. I WILL
SIMPLY STATES- THE FITS AND
STARTS MAKE. COULD MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR THOSE PROVIDERS
TO IMPLEMENT. EFFECTIVELY AND-
FOR BETTER LONG TERM PLANNING
WOULD BE NICE TO GIVE THEM THAT
CLARITY- BUT- WITH THAT I WILL
TURN OVER QUESTIONS TO-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. THANK
YOU I'M BEING THAT- WE'VE BEEN
IN LAW THIS IS MY FOURTH YEAR
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND THEN.
THIS WHOLE- SOME SUSPENSION NON
SUSPENSION IS REALLY CONFUSING
AND- THE ONLY THING THAT I
WOULD OR THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO YOU
KNOW I PUT MY SITUATION- MYSELF
IN THE OF THE PLACE OF FOLKS.
KIND OF IN MY OWN PERSONAL
BUDGET- AND MY OWN KIND OF
INCOME AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO PLAN- YOU KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT LOOKING FORWARD IF
THEY'RE UNDER THREAT OF. IT'S
BEEN SUSPENDED NOT SUSPENDED
YOU KNOW. AGAIN IT'S VERY
CONFUSING. BUT I THINK THAT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THE PROVIDERS
pPAYMENTS SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE- THE SERVICES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER WE DONT
SUSPENDED OR SUSPENDED HOWEVER
WE WANT TO SAY IT BECAUSE AGAIN
IT'S REALLY CONFUSING BUT THE
POINT IS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THAT THESE PAYMENTS-
ARE STEADY SO THAT- NOT ONLY
THE PROVIDERS CAN PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE BUT AT LEAST WE HAVE
SOME ASSURANCES THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE GETTING THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED- AND
THE ONLY WAY TO GET. THOSE
SERVICES AS BY MAKING SURE THAT
PROVIDERS. HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES-
SO IT'S AGAIN IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND AND I
THINK. YOU KNOW IN SOME
INSTANCES I THINK IT'S ON
PURPOSE I'M NOT SAYING BAGHDAD.
THAT THAT. THIS IS INTENTIONAL
HOWEVER THE CONFUSION. S. IS
ARE NOT JUST FOR ME BUT I THINK
FOR OUR FOLKS THEY NEED THOSE
SERVICES. ONE ONE. YEAR THEY
CAN GET SERVICES THE NEXT YEAR
THEY CAN'T AND SO. WE NEED SOME
STABILITY AND I'M PLEADING WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND I'M PLANNING
WITH WITH THE YOU KNOW KIND OF
ANYBODY THAT'S IN CHARGE OF
THESE PROGRAMS THAT. WE CAN'T.
OF HAVE THESE ISSUES HANGING
OVER PEOPLE'S HEADS BECAUSE IN
THE SERVICES ARE NOT BEING
PROVIDED- TO LOOK AT THE END OF
THE DAY THAT SERVICE IS NOT ARE
NOT BEING PROVIDED TO OUR
COMMUNITY SO. AGAIN I PLEAD
WITH ALL OF US TO KEEP TRYING
AND YOU KNOW COME UP WITH A
PLAN THAT ASSURES A PROVIDERS
THAT THEY WILL GET PAID.
APPROPRIATELY MOVING FORWARD WE
YOU KNOW OUR OUR FISCAL-
SITUATION IS GOOD AND IT'S
PROJECTED TO NOT BE THAT GREAT.
BUT IF WE DON'T PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO OUR COMMUNITY THEN.
WE HAVE A REAL PEOPLE'S LIVES
AT STAKE YOUR SOUL THANK YOU.
THE DOCTOR WOULD. THANK END
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPRESENTATION HI I WONDER HAS
THE DEPARTMENT EVER CONSIDERED
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE ON A
MULTI YEAR BASIS FOR EXAMPLE A
COUPLE OF YEARS INSTEAD OF A
SINGLE YEAR- YOU KNOW YEAH I
THINK YOU ALL KNOW THE HISTORY
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE KNOW
THE HISTORY THAT. THAT
SENSUALLY THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
PUT PROP FIFTY SIX TOGETHER
WE'RE TOLD THAT YOU KNOW THERE
REALLY ISN'T MONEY IN THE STATE
BUDGET TEAM INCREASE RATES AND
SO. THE CHALLENGE WAS TO GO OUT
AND FIND REVENUE SOURCE WHICH
THEY DID AND PASS THIS PASSED
AS PROPOSITION. WHICH HAS NOW
BEEN YOU KNOW USED IN DIFFERENT
WAYS- NOT ALWAYS TO THE INTENT
OF THAT WELL WHAT HOW IT WAS
WRITTEN. SO KNOWING THAT YOU
KNOW THAT IT'S CHALLENGING TO
GET PROVIDERS TO PARTICIPATE
LONG TERM. IS THERE ANY
POSSIBILITY THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COULD NOT LOOK AT THIS
AS A LINE ITEM BUT LOOK AT IT
IN WHOLE MORE HOLISTICALLY. AS
AN INVESTMENT IN TREATING THE
MOST NEEDY POPULATION OF OUR
STATE. AND LOOK AT THIS AND
FIND CONSIDER FINDING THIS ON A
MULTI YEAR BASIS. ALL THE PARTS
YOU ARE COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ELEMENT
REQUIREMENTS LININGS THE-
SUSPENSIONS ARE AN EXTENSION OF
THE STATE LIGHTS SUSPENSIONS
REMARKS. BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION WILL MARK MY
WORDS BACK WORKABLE ISN'T
STANDING AT BY ONE ADDITIONAL
YEAR AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT IT
AND NOT. WHAT ARE YOUR THE L.
A. O. AND THEN MOST RECENTLY WE
ARE THE STATE APPEARS TO BE
FIGHTING FOR A LARGE BUDGET
DEFICITS WALMART SUSPENSIONS
REMARKED AS NECESSARY TO
MITIGATE THIS BUDGET. BUDGET
DEFICITS. BRING SEASONS FROM
FRAMEWORK RESULT IN THE STATE
OF THE- TO MAKE THE SOLDIERS
AND. APOLOGIES COMMITTEE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. START OUT
WORKING APART THANK YOU SIR. SO
BUT BUT I WOULD GUESS IT WAS
THAT EVEN WHEN WE GOOD YEAR.
THE THERE WAS NO IT TO AT IT
THIS WAY IT'S IT THAT OFTEN
JUST FEELS LIKE IT'S A- IT'S
ALMOST A- OF THIS SOURCE OF
REVENUE THAT THAT SEEMS TO BE.
STE SPENT IN A WAY THAT'S YOU
KNOW. YOU'VE CLEARLY HEARD THE
REAL LEGISLATURE LEASE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS STRONG DESIRE TO
SEE HOW THIS IS SPENT AND
ALLOCATED. YET EVEN IN THE GOOD
YEARS. THAT YOU KNOW LOOKING AT
THIS OVER A MULTI YEAR BASIS
NEVER HAPPENED AND NOW WE CAN
USE THE PROJECTIONS OF THE
FUTURE AS A WAY TO FURTHER
FORCED ALL THAT- I THINK THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE
PROVIDER BASE THAT THAT SERVES
THESE NEEDY POCKET THIS NEEDY
POPULATION. NEEDS STABILITY
AND- AND PART OF THAT STABILITY
LEADS TO BETTER QUALITY CARE
MORE TIMELY CARE AND
POTENTIALLY LESS COST TO THE
STATE OF PEOPLE KING. DICTUM WE
GET THE CARE THEY NEED FROM
TRUSTED PROVIDERS WHEN THEY
NEED IT SO SON CERTAINTY. IS
NOT HELPFUL AND WHILE YOU MAY
THINK AS THE DEPARTMENT THAT
THIS IS YOU KNOW WILL SOUND WAY
OF BUDGETING THINGS. FROM A
HUMAN PERSPECTIVE IT'S REALLY
NOT AND- AND I WOULD JUST
IMPLORE. THE DEPARTMENT AT SOME
POINT ON THIS ISSUE AND OTHERS
TO NOT NECESSARILY LOOK AT
THESE AS LINE ITEMS LOOK AT
THEM AT THE HUMAN IMPACT AND
THE PROPHETIC CARE IMPACT
THAT'S HAPPENING FOR PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
KNOW THAT'S A BIG PARADIGM
SHIFT BUT YOU KNOW WHEN WE LOOK
AT OTHER THINGS OUT THERE YOU
KNOW PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. THAT OFTEN
GET PUSHED ASIDE- THIS IS JUST.
THE UNCERTAINTY IS LEADING TO A
POTENTIALLY UNCERTAINTY AMONG
PROVIDERS AND POTENTIALLY POOR
OUTCOMES WHICH IN THE LONG RUN
ACROSS ACTUALLY BECAUSE THE
STATE MORE MONEY. SO I'M JUST
AT SOME POINT YEAH CAN WE
CHANGE THE PARADIGM A LITTLE
BIT AND LOOK AT THESE THINGS
MORE HOLISTICALLY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS. I JUST WANT A
SECOND DOCTOR WAS MOTION. TO
LOOK AT THIS- MORE HOLISTICALLY.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR THERE ARE
NO VOTES HERE TODAY. TAKING NO
MOTIONS- BUT I WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE TO THANK PANEL THREE AS WE
MOVE ON THE PANEL FOR. ON THE
PROPOSAL TO MAKE CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS A COVERED
BENEFIT AND THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. WE HAVE JUST TWO
PRESENTERS DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN
IN JC COOPER PLEASE BEGIN.
THERE WILL BE 1% OF COOPER.
THANK YOU- SO EFFECTIVE JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWO OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING ELEVEN
MILLION A TOTAL FUND FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO ADD ON
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS AS
A COVERED MEDICARE BENEFIT- FOR
BENEFICIARIES TWENTY ONE AND
OLDER WE CURRENTLY ALREADY DO
COVER- CGM'S IS WHAT I MEAN IS
FOR SHARPER I'M GENIUS BECAUSE
MONITORS- FOR INDIVIDUALS
TWENTY ONE AND UNDER THROUGH
BOTH CCS AND IN ALL MEDICAL-
COMPLETELY. ON THE DEPARTMENT-
WILL ALSO BE ENTERING INTO
REBATE AGREEMENTS WITH THE
VARIOUS MANUFACTURERS FOR THE-
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITOR
SYSTEMS AND SUPPLIES ON THE
REBATES WILL HELP OFFSET THE
GENERAL FUND. COSTS OF SUCH
COVERAGE. I'M SO WE WANT TO
WALK THROUGH US IN THE
QUESTIONS AROUND A TYPE TWO
DIABETES- YOU KNOW THE VALUE OF
CGM'S IN INDIVIDUALS WITH TYPE
ONE- HAS BEEN WELL
DEMONSTRATED- AND RESEARCHED-
HOWEVER THERE IS LIMITED
EVIDENCE. IN CURRENT LITERATURE
AROUND CGM'S FOR A BENEFITS FOR
TYPE TWO DIABETES- ESPECIALLY
LONG TERM I RESEARCH THAT HAS.
SHOWN TO IT TO BE EFFECTIVE FOR
TYPE TWO- FOR TYPE ONE
DIABETES- OF THE PATIENTS TO
USE INSULIN- AT THE BODY
DOESN'T PRODUCE THE HORMONE
INSULIN. FOR TYPE TWO DIABETES-
OCCURS WHEN BLOOD SUGAR LEVELS
I BECOME ELEVATED AND DEVELOP
INSULIN RESISTANCE AND CAN BE
MANAGED WITH OTHER TREATMENTS-
TREATMENT FOR TYPE TWO DIABETES
MAY INCLUDE A COMBINATION OF
ANY O THE FOLLOWING DIET
EXERCISE OR MEDICATION AND
INSULIN- SO SOME PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TYPE TWO DIABETES AND NEED
INSULIN THERAPY IF THEIR BLOOD
SUGAR TARGETS. AREN'T MET- WITH
LIFESTYLE CHANGES OR OTHER
MEDICATIONS- I'M- AND A CGM
WOULD BE AVAILABLE- TWO ADULTS
WITH TYPE TWO DIABETES WHEN TED
A TREATING PHYSICIAN DETERMINES
THAT THAT WOULD BE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY- AND- THE BEST
TREATMENT FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL.
HOWEVER THEY WOULD NEED TO
SUBMIT A AN AUTHORIZATION
REQUEST TO THE DEPARTMENT DO
YOU HAVE THAT COVERED- HOWEVER
WOULD JUST NOTE AGAIN THAT MOST
PEOPLE WHO USE AS CGM'S HAVE
TYPE ONE DIABETES- A RESEARCH-
IS VERY STRONG THERE. I'M IN
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE DONNELLY
PROPOSING TO COVER THERE BUT
AGAIN TYPE TWO DIABETES CAN BE
COVERED I'M WITH AN
AUTHORIZATION- I WOULD ALSO
JUST I WANNA HIGHLIGHT IN
REGARDS TO MEDICAL NECESSITY-
QUESTION FOR TYPE ONE DIABETES.
I'M INDIVIDUALS OF WOULD BE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE MEDICAL
NECESSITY BY HAVING A TREATING
PHYSICIAN- OPPOSE THAT I'M
INCLUDING THE- INTENSIVE
INSULIN THERAPY THAT THE PERSON
WOULD NEED- HAS A LOW BLOOD
SUGAR- ARE AND AWARENESS OF
SUCH THINGS. AND OFTEN. HAS
HIGHER LOW BLOOD GLUCOSE I THE
INTO. SOCIETY RIGHT YOU. WHAT
TYPE ONE DAY WHO HAVE HE- A.
ONE C. YOU'VE GOT. OF 7% AND
WHO HAVE SHOWN THAT THEY CAN
USE THESE DEVICES NEARLY EVERY
DAY ABOUT SPECIFIC GUIDELINES
FOR THE AUTHORIZATION APPROVAL
ARE STILL UNDER REVIEW BY THE
DEPARTMENT- MEDICARE WILL
LARGELY. FOLLOW MEDICARE
GUIDELINES AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE ITEMS THAT I JUST
REFERENCED HERE TODAY- SO THAT
CONCLUDES ALL OF OUR COMMENTS
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WILL BRING IT
UP TO THE DICE TO SEE IF
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE I WILL APPRECIATE
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
PROPOSAL- HAVING A FATHER IN
LAW WHO HAS BENEFITED FROM
BEING ON A C. G. AM I THINK
THIS IS LONG OVERDUE FOR US AS
A STATE. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
VERY MUCH THANK PANEL FOR WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL PANEL. ON
THE PROPOSED RESTORATION OF THE
MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR OVER THE
COUNTER COUGH COLD AND
ACETAMINOPHEN PRODUCTS AGAIN WE
HAVE TWO PRESENTERS DIRECTOR
LIFE BORN IN J. C. COOPER. IF
YOU CAN PLEASE BEGIN. ALL RIGHT
MISS COOPER YEAH. SO HERE THE
DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING A
TRAILER BILL- TO REINSTATE OVER
THE COUNTER ADULT COUGH AND
COLD PRODUCTS EFFECTIVE JULY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE- WHICH
WOULD RESULT IN A TOTAL SAVINGS
OF TWENTY ONE MILLION- DOLLARS
TOTAL FUN AND SEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND- THE MAY
TWENTY TWENTY S. MAY INCLUDE
THE IMPACT OF THE REINSTATEMENT
OF THESE DRUG PRODUCTS AS WELL-
HOWEVER THAT PROPOSAL WAS ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS DURING PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS MAKE THAT A
PERMANENT CHANGE WITHIN THE
MEDICAL BENEFITS- HISTORICALLY
MEDI CAL- HAD COVERED OVER THE
COUNTER DRUGS. I'M AS AN
INEXPENSIVE ALTERNATIVE- TO
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS THE PROPOSAL
DOES A LINE- THE PHARMACY
BENNETT WITH BENEFIT WITH WHAT
IS COVERED DOMINI FIRE MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO CURRENTLY
I DO COVER OVER THE COUNTER
DRUGS- IN REALLY IS TO IN ORDER
TO PREVENT TRANSITION TO A
MORE- YOU KNOW EXPENSIVE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG BENEFITS-
THERE'S A NUMBER OF BENEFITS
WHICH I'LL OUTLINE QUICKLY I'M
IT DOES PROVIDE FOR A SAFER
AND- KIND OF QUALITY EFFECTIVE
MEDICATION ALTERNATIVES
INCREASE USE OF NON OPIOID
MEDICATION ALTERNATIVES MAY
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
FREQUENT- AND COSTLIER MEDIT-
MEDICAL VISITS- REDUCES THE
COST TO THE STATE RESULTING
FROM LESS COSTLY PRODUCTS BEING
UTILIZED AS WELL AS DECREASED
NEED. TO PROVIDE OPIOID
DEPENDENT A RELATED TREATMENTS
THE PRODUCTS ARE EVIDENCE BASED
AND ONLY YOU- USE OVER THE
COUNTER DRUGS WHEN REVIEWED BY
DH CS CLINICAL PHARMACISTS AND
LISTED AS IN ALLOWED OVER THE
COUNTER- PRESCRIPTION IN THE
MEDIC HOW- DRUG LIST AS A
COVERED BENEFIT SO WE WOULD BE
LISTING THEM AND OUR CONTRACT
DRUG LIST SO THAT PEOPLE ARE
AWARE OF WHICH. OVER THE
COUNTER DRUGS WE DO COVER. I'M
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY THIS. AND
BUILD FOR MANY BENEFITS REQUIRE
PRESCRIPTION ON FILE. WITH THE
DISPENSING PHARMACY VERIFYING
THE PRESCRIBER FOUND THE
DISPENSED MEDICATION TO BE
MEDICALLY NECESSARY A FOR
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT. OF THE
PATIENTS I'M ALSO UP WE- HAVE
NOTED THAT ABSENT THE
AVAILABILITY OF NON NARCOTIC
PAIN CONTROL. I'M NARCOTIC
BASED MEDICATIONS WOULD LIKELY
HAVE TO BE PRESCRIBED- AND
WHILE WE CANNOT DIRECTLY
CORRELATE HOW THIS MAY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO INCREASE
PRESCRIPTION- SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
WE DO KNOW THAT EVIDENCE EXISTS
OF RELATIVE TO THE OVER USE OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS PAIN
RELIEVERS. I MEAN DO YOU THINK
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS
APPROPRIATE- GIVEN THAT- AND SO
THAT CONCLUDES OUR ALL OF OUR
COMMENTS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I WILL
BRING IT UP TO THE DíAS FOR
THE MEMBER QUESTIONS. SEEING
NONE I WILL THANK THIS PANEL
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE ON- TO
PUBLIC COMMENT I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY. AS A
REMINDER WE WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE ON THE
AGENDA INCLUDING THE NON
PRESENTATION ISSUES SIX THROUGH
THIRTEEN. WE HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEREFORE I WANT TO URGE YOU TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS AS BRIEF AS
YOU CAN SO THAT WE CAN HEAR
FROM EVERYONE. WE WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AS A REMINDER THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ALSO
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. 1-877-692-8957 THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO
BEGIN PUBLIC TOM. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO AND WE GO
TO OUR FIRST PUBLIC COMMENT
WHICH IS FROM THE LINE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DR ARAMBULA NGT ACTS ON BEHALF
OF AND YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA I'D
LIKE TO SHARE SUPPORT ON TWO
ITEMS. UNDER ISSUE NUMBER ONE
WE SUPPORT THE HEALTH FALL
PROPOSAL TAKES. MANY COUNTY
COVERAGE TO INCOME ELIGIBLE
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS SEIU
HAS LONG SUPPORTED THE HEALTH
FOR ALL INITIATIVES THAT
EXCEPTION BECAUSE MANY OF OUR
OWN- WORKERS. FAMILY MEMBERS
ACTUALLY FALL INTO THIS
CATEGORY AND ARE IN DIRE NEED
OF HEALTH COVERAGE NOW MORE
THAN EVER. SECOND UNDER ISSUE
NUMBER THREE WE ARE PLEASED TO
SEE THAT THE FUNCTION OF
PROPERTY FIX SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT AN OPTIONAL BENEFIT
CUTS THIS YEAR BUT WE DO
REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE ENSURE
FUTURE PROP FIFTY SIX- PAYMENTS
AN OPTIONAL BENEFIT. ACTUALLY
MAKE PERMANENT AND NO LONGER
SUSCEPTIBLE TO FUTURE PENSION
WE AGREE WITH THE L. A. L.
POSITION FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
REJECT ONGOING SUSPENSION
BUDGET LANGUAGE BECAUSE LET'S
JUST BE HONEST AND CLEAR THAT
THESE WOULD BAKED IN FUTURE
CUTS OF IMPORTANT PAYMENTS AND
NEEDED BENEFITS. WE THANK DR
WOULD FOR THE COMMENTS ON THIS
ISSUE AND WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
THE LEGISLATURE. ORDER
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD NEVER
BEGIN FUTURE BUDGET CUTS ON
CRITICAL PROGRAMS THAT BACK AND
ACTUALLY BENEFIT THE MOST
VULNERABLE. POPULATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ALAINA THIRTY
TWO YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. HELLO
DEAR MEMBERS IS MICHAEL EVAN
HILBURN HOW NONPARTISAN OLD
CHILD THESE POLICY IN
ORGANIZATION I WANT TO QUICKLY
COMING ON I REMEMBER READING
THE PART OF AFRICAN LEMONADE.
ARE THE. WHEN WE THEY MIGHT BE
DAMAGE TO COULD NOT GOING TO
PROVIDER RECRUITMENT. ACT THE
DIGITAL NEEDED VERY YOU
CANCELING. I THINK WE THE ONLY
TO. YOUNG OUT THE MOMENT WOULD
THE HARD TO BE OUT WHO IN THE
FIRST PLACE NO WAY NEXT YEAR. I
BE HEARD CONTINUE TO THE.
SUPPORT TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
RELATED TO CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORS YOU THINK THIS WILL
INCREASE PATIENT. OUTCOMES AND
REDUCE OVERALL HEALTHCARE COSTS
IN THE LONG RUN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND A FIFTY SEVEN YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. CHAT ONLINE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS NOT A VALID AND I'M
STATE POLICY SENIOR MANAGER
WITH THE LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
PROUD SUPPORTERS OF CULTURAL WE
ARE THE LONGEST SERVING
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON IMPROVING THE HEALTH
OUTCOMES OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. THE
SINGLE MOST CRITICAL BARRIER TO
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
THE LATINO COMMUNITY IS ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE ITSELF YOU HAVE
HEARD TODAY THE ECONOMIC
ARGUMENT AS TO WHY IT IS IN THE
INTEREST OF OUR STATE TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
ARE FACING UNPRECEDENTED HEALTH
CRISIS THERE ARE QUITE A TO
CARE FOR EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE CAN DEFEAT
IT ADAMEC AT LOWES PREVENT
FUTURE PANDEMICS THAT NEXUS
DEMOCRATS UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES ARE
BURDENED WITH STRUCTURAL
BARRIERS THAT RESULT IN
COMPOUNDED NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES THAT CORBETT NINETEEN
HAVE EXPOSED. WE CANNOT AFFORD
THIS CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE A
LEADER IN ENSURING THAT HEALTH
IS A HUMAN RIGHT FOR ALL RIGHT
OR YOU DO SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
GUARANTEE DRIVING FEATURES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BY SIX FIVE YOUR
AT THE- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO I
BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE HEALTH FOR ALL
PROPOSALS TO EXPAND MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS WE SUPPORT THE MEDIA AT
NEXTSTEP EXPAND MEDICAL
COVERAGE TO UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS SENIORS AND THEY ARE
THE MOST AT RISK. DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC NON
CITIZENS CONTINUE TO SACRIFICE
FOR OUR CITIZENS IN
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND THE COASTAL
REGION NEARLY ONE MILLION FARM
WORKERS MOST OF WHOM ARE
UNDOCUMENTED HAVE RISK GREATLY
TO FEED THE STATE FARM DIANNE
AT HIGHER RATES THAN OTHER
OCCUPATIONS. DESPITE THE
SACRIFICE UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT FARM WORKERS AND
FAMILIES ARE EXCLUDED FROM FULL
SCOPE MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY CRLA
FOUNDATION SUPPORT THE HELP FOR
A PROPOSAL TO REMOVE
UNDOCUMENTED STATUS THE BEAR
TAXES LIFESAVING HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE FOR SENIORS THANK YOU
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON HELP FOR
ALL AND THE OTHER PROPOSALS. TO
HELP FARMWORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
CALL PLEASE. A LINE OF SIXTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY KIDDO. GOOD
AFTERNOON DIANA DOUGLAS ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA AND ISSUE NUMBER ONE
RELATED TO COVER CALIFORNIA WE
WELCOME THE FORTHCOMING FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES THAT WILL FURTHER CAP
PREMIUMS ON WHICH CALIFORNIA
HELPED PAVE THE WAY FOR WE HAVE
FIVE COVER CALIFORNIA'S WORK
ALONG WITH A COMMITMENT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
TO MOVE US TOWARD UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE. OUR WORK IS NOT DONE
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
REPURPOSE EXISTING INVESTMENT
IN AFFORDABILITY AND STATE
SUBSIDIES TO GO FARTHER IN
KEEPING COSTS DOWN ESPECIALLY
TO ADDRESS THE SOARING
DEDUCTIBLES ARE HIGH COST OF
LIVING STATE. ON ISSUE NUMBER
THREE WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DELAY OF SOME
OF THE MEDIC HELP THE PENSIONS
BUT ULTIMATELY WE CALL FOR A
PERMANENT REINSTATEMENT OF
THESE BENEFITS AND PAYMENTS
INCLUDING THE. PROPERTY SIX
PROVIDER CANNOT. I AM AND IF
YOU THINK SEVEN AND A WITH THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN. AGENCIES
REQUESTS FOR RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT SB FIFTY TWO TO MAKE
GENERIC DRUGS MORE AFFORDABLE
TO CALIFORNIANS. THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE'S
REQUEST TO RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
AND SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. FINE
THIRTY ONE YOUR MY GET UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON AWAY WITH WASHINGTON
ON ON POVERTY LIKE TO COMMENT
ON THREE ITEMS BAKALY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO REGULAR
HEALTH CARE AND THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST NOW IT'S
PRECISELY THE TIME TO FILL IN
THE GAPS IN OUR MEDICARE
PROGRAM SO WE SUPPORT THE
REQUEST TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL TO
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE LEFT OUT DUE
TO THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE OVER SIXTY
FIVE WHO ARE MOST AT RISK
DURING THE PANIC AND IN MOST
NEED OF HEALTH CARE TO ADDRESS
CHRONIC CONDITIONS IN ADDITION
WE AGREE WITH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO ELIMINATE THE
PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDING
SUSPENSION COMPLETELY IT TOOK
OVER TEN YEARS TO RESTORE
CRITICAL MEDICARE BENEFITS
INCLUDING EYEGLASSES AUDIOLOGY
IN SPEECH THERAPY SO
TECHNICALLY CUT THESE BENEFITS
NEXT YEAR IT'S NOT REASSURING
TO PATIENTS TO OPEN. IN MAY
ALREADY BE. DELAYING CARE DUE
TO THE PENDEK. BY WE SUPPORT
ADDING CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITOR. AS A MEDIC CAL BENEFIT
PULL CAL. ARE ALMOST TWICE AS
LIKELY TO HAVE DIABETES. AND
THOSE WITH HIGHER INCOMES AND
THESE MONITORS WILL HELP
PATIENTS AND A CONTROL THAT
COULD CAUSE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLIND A FIFTY FIVE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME OF THE RUN
BUT I I'M I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND HELP FOR ALL
STATEWIDE COALITION I'M CALLING
AT THE PORT OF ISSUE NUMBER
ONE. HEALTH FOR ALL IS
UNACCEPTABLE THAT NEARLY ONE
MILLION TAX PAYING CALIFORNIANS
ARE LOCKED OUT OF CARE AND
DYING SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS AVNET AND
HELP SOME OF THE HARD WORKING
RESIDENTS OF THE HEALTH
INSURANCE CASE MANAGER MANY
YEARS AGO. I WITNESSED THEIR
FRUSTRATION WHEN TOLD THAT THEY
DID NOT QUALIFY FOR ANY HEALTH
COVERAGE DUE TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. ANY OF
THESE RESIDENTS. HAVE NO SAFETY
NET WHEN IT COMES TO OBTAIN
HEALTH CARE. AND THEY ARE
INCREASINGLY AT RISK IN FRONT
LIKE JOBS AND THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO TAKE TIME OFF. IT IS TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA TO TRULY BE A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL BY MOVING
TO HEALTHCARE. HAS HELP FROM
OUT TO HELP US GET OUT OF IT
AND THEN THEY CAN TRULY CREATE
A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE NUMBER TWELVE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LISBETH MENDOZA WITH
INLAND COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE AND THE HEALTH FOR ALL
STATE. CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BE A
LEADER ENSURING THAT HEALTH IS
A HUMAN RIGHT FOR ALL I KNOW WE
PROCLAIM THIS MANY TIMES- OUT
IN OUR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS AT
HOME IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AT
THE STATE CAPITOL AND EVERY
TIME WE DO THAT I REMEMBER THE
OF UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY THAT
I WORK WITH EVERY DAY- WHO HAVE
SHARED MORE RECENTLY HOW THE-
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET CHECK
UPS AND YEARS. AND I WOULD CALL
THE- THEY THEY'RE HEARING
ABOUT- EXISTING CONDITIONS THAT
THEY THEY DIDN'T KNOW OF- AND
THANKFULLY THEY WERE ABLE TO
GET CARE- THROUGH UNDER DIRE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH OF THIS
PANDEMIC BUT THEY REALIZE MORE
AND MORE EVERY YEARTHAT IF
THEY'RE NOT HEALTHY THEY CAN'T
WORK AND THEIR FAMILIES SUFFER.
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE INCLUDED THE
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FOR FAR TOO LONG
FOR MY HEALTH SYSTEM AND WE
NEED YOU OFFICE SUPPORT HEALTH
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. IN THE
STATE BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE
LINE FORTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON DR-
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT RONALD
KOEMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR REGULAR FOR HOLDING
TODAY'S HEARING YOUR UNWAVERING
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE IS
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED BY THE
PEN AND THE HAVING ARCTIC
COLLISION. RACISM CONTINUES TO
BE A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT
REMAINS ON THE DRAFT AND THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
MADE MORE GLOBAL AND
EXACERBATED THE MAGNITUDE OF
HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT RESULT
IN THE EXPICIT COLLUSION LIKE
BARRING MOST UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS FROM THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. THESE DISPARITIES
RESULT IN DEADLY OUTCOMES ARE
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WERE
SYSTEMATICALLY EXCLUDED FROM
OUR SOCIAL SAFETY NET WILL
THEIR FAMILIES STRUGGLE TO PAY
FOR NEEDED HEALTHCARE WE'RE
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF GEEKING
SURE THAT WE CAN EXPAND HEALTH
CARE FOR SENIORS THIS YEAR AND
CONTINUING TO EXPAND EXPAND TO
ALL UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS MOVING
FORWARD WILL ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER THREE-
AND RECOMMEND- ELIMINATION IN
FACT THE PROBLEM OPPOSITION
FIFTY SIX- PAYMENT SUSPENSIONS
WHICH ARE CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR
CHILDREN'S HEALTH CARE AND
MEDICAL PROGRAM. PAYMENTS FOR
WELL CHILD CHECKUPS DON'T
DEVELOPMENTAL AND THOMAS
GREENING PROVIDER TRAINING FOR
TRAUMA SCREENING IN LOAN
REPAYMENTS FOR PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS WHEN VOTERS APPROVED
PROP FIFTY SIX IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN IT WAS WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THOSE ON
MEDI CAL THAT POOR ACCESS TO
SERVICES RESULTING FROM LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND
PROVIDER PARTICIPATION.
LEGISLATIVE STAFF RECOMMEND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
REJECTING THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSAL TO DELAY THE
SUSPENSIONS AND INSTEAD OF
PROOF ELIMINATING THE
SUSPENSIONS ALTOGETHER AND WE
ENDORSE AND SUPPORT THAT AFTER
A RECOMMENDATION OF ELIMINATION
OF THE PROPERTY SIX PAYMENT
SUSPENSION FURTHER C. BUT HE
CAN SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
TO ALLOCATE TWELVE MILLION-
DOLLARS FOUR POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO ADD CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORING SYSTEMS OF A MEDIC
CAL BENEFIT. FOR BENEFICIARIES
AGED TWENTY ONE AND OLDER WITH
DIABETES THEY'RE ALSO- IS EIGHT
RECOMMENDATIONS SPECIFICALLY IN
OUR EQUITY IN THE AGE OF
TELEHEALTH REPORT- AND WE THINK
THAT WHILE. THIS STEP IS
IMPORTANT IT WILL BE CRITICAL
FOR THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT
THIS BETTER OF INPUT. AT AND-
L. A. MEDIC BENEFITS ARE MADE.
OF INTRIGUED ADVANTAGE OF THIS
GIVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE- LINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR
MIKE IT'S OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS MICHELLE
GAIL AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER I AM CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM NUMBER ONE- CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE A LEADER INSURING
THAT HEALTH IS A HUMAN RIGHT
FOR ALL MILLIONS OF ARE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS AFFECTED
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND SENIORS DISPROPORTIONATELY
SO OUT WE ARE ENCOURAGING OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND OUR
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE- LINE
NINETEEN YOUR MY COULD HELP. HI
MY NAME IS RICARDO THOUGHT-
FROM BY CELLULAR CALIFORNIA AND
SENATOR GROSS DISTRICT I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF YOUNG
INVINCIBLE BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT IT IT IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT
OVER A MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM CARE AND ARE
DYING BECAUSE OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. MANY OF MY
FRIENDS AND FAMILY HAVE PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS THAT
WITHOUT TREATMENT THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO DIE OF CARBON
NINETEEN ANOTHER MEMBER OF MY
FAMILY IS PAYING MORE THAN
THEIR MORTGAGE PAYMENT FOR
HEALTH INSURANCE BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT COVERED UNDER COVER
CALIFORNIA SO- I WE URGE YOU
TO- TO. CONTINUE ON WITH HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE FORTY FOUR YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. HI EVERYONE- THIS IS
THOUGHT I'D MEDINA FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WHICH I'M
TALKING ABOUT YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO THE FEDERAL UNITY CAN NOW I
CAN YOU DIDN'T ADD COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
WITH INDIGENOUS FARMWORKERS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY- AND
ALSO THE CENTRAL COAST- THANK
YOU DR AMALEK COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR- HOLDEN DIFFERENT PARTY
LEADERS. IN THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
I THINK MENTION WE WORK WITH
INDIGENOUS FARMWORKERS THE
WOULD- ALREADY AND IN GENERAL
FUND MARKET BUT LACKS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE MANY OF THEM ON
BACKING ON IT- AND THAT WE KNOW
THAT THE HILL DISPARITIES- ARE
SOME DAYS- REALLY- RATES OF
STRUCTURES THAT DODGE REALLY
BLOCKED ACCESS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND SAID THAT IN
THIS CRITICAL KINDS WITH THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE REALLY BENCH- HE
DEVASTATED IN TERMS OF OUR
COMMUNITY IN A LONG EACH YEAR-
ACTIONS HEALTH CARE BECAUSE OF
LANGUAGE AND CULTURAL.
DIFFERENCES OF THE SYSTEM NOT
UNDERSTANDING THEIR NEEDS BUT
ALSO BECAUSE OF THE FEAR AND
HOPE ALL OF YOU KNOW- ACCESSING
SERVICES BECAUSE OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS SO I REALLY URGE ALL OF
YOU TO. BE LEADERS IN TO HELP
WITH THE LEAD IN THE STATE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE A MODEL FOR
THE COUNTRY AND ENSURING THAT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE HEART
CENTRAL WORKERS THE NEED TO
BOTH THE FINANCIAL SERVICES IN
A SENSE OF ME. GET ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SO I URGE YOU ALL
TO DEPLOY RESUMELIST FORWARD
INTO BE LEADER SADDAM WITH A
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. PINE TWENTY
YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. WELL I
MEAN I'M GONNA A LONGTIME AND
ALSO HE SAID PLAYED SOME WHEN
CANNOT COME ON PROJECT AND AS
AS A PUBLIC MUSLIM ON THE CALL
MOST NOTICEABLE THAT ENGENDERS
THAT THERE ONE DAM GO YOU MIGHT
HAVE SEEN THEM THE BUSHES THAT
DOES MEAN THE AUDIO. THANK YOU
MEMBER I A SPANIEL BE IF WE
SPEAK WITH A TECHNICAL THAT THE
COMING DATA THE LETTER SAID
THAT INGREDIENTS ON THE SPOT IS
SO FRIENDLY PROBLEM OF THIS
FELLOW BUT I HAVE TO- FOR
EXPLICA DIED IN A CAR AND I
DAUGHTER IS COMPOSED YEAH BONTA
SHADOW OR DOES IT THE FEDERAL
HAVE BEEN SAKE I. OF THE END AS
OF BY A MAJOR NOT OF THE I WANT
TO PROGRAM I MEDICAL I'M IN THE
DIOCESE BECAUSE THAT ON THE
DOOR BUT IT'S NOT WHAT WHAT
DOES IT INTERNET GOT. ONE MUST
GIVE I GUESS. ABOUT THE ONLY
THEM TODAY ONE OF MY NEXT BEGIN
ASKING YOU GUYS ESTIMATE BY
THAT I'M AS HE SAID THAT HE
NEVER LEFT. I DO NOT KNOW THE
VALUE OF THIS AND THEY MAKE
TODAY CAT WELL CALIFORNIA I
THINK THAT PEOPLE BUT A BILL OF.
YES YES MISSISSINEWA NEXT
REPLACE. ALIGNING AT FOUR YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. I AFTERNOON THIS
IS MOLINA CAL STATE RIGHT OF
MEETING FLIPPED THE IN REGARDS
TO ITEM ONE WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF A MEDICAID ACCESS TO
ALL CAL REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. A LINE OF FORTY THREE
YOUR MY GET UP. THANK YOU HELLO
DOCTOR RAN PLAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
MALLEABILITY CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND I'D LIKE TO TAKE
A MINUTE JUST TO TALK ABOUT-
OUR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NUMBER
ONE AND IN HEALTH FOR ALL. THE
LABOR MOVEMENT HAS FOUGHT FOR
YEARS FOR HIGH QUALITY HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND WORKERS UNDER UNION
CONTRACTS HAVE THE SAME ACCESS
TO EMPLOYER SPONSORED UNION
NEGOTIATED HEALTH BENEFITS.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS AN ETHNICALLY AND
SERRANO ALAMOS THAT TERRY
CATCHING. A CAB TODAY. AND THE
REALITY OF THE TREMENDOUS
IMPACT AND ON AND OUR STATE.
WHERE ONE INSTEAD ALL THE CAL.
THAT HAVE AT LEAST ONE ON
PARENTS AND- AT THAT IN
NINETEEN. HAS HIT- THE
UNDOCUMENTED. AND VERY- VERY
HORRIBLE WAYS WE URGE YOU
SUPPORT. AND- HELPS THANK YOU.
THE YOU MA'AM NOT CALLER PLEASE.
ALIGNED NO NINE YOU'RE MY KIDDO.
HI MY NAME IS DON COHEN I'M
WITH THE POWER HOW PROFESSION
THE DEADLINE FOR THE YOU DON'T
TO KEEP. UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
OF ALL AGES ARE IN CONTINUE TO
LOCK THE FIXING OUT OF PUBLIC
INCLUDING HELPING AND HEALTH
CARE IT IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT
APPEARED THE FAMILY WORKING TO
CONDITION THE PACKER PRECARITY
AND A CALL TO DO BEFORE MAKE
THE POINT THE HELP FROM A
LITTLE. LINE NINETY TWO YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME IS OMAR
BY G. AND I'M FROM THE BERKELEY
CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS IN
THE LINE THAT'S PART OF THE
STUDENT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WE ARE HERE TO SUPPORT HELPFUL
WHICH OF ISSUE NUMBER ONE SH
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE THE OVER A
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE LOCKED
OUT OF CARE AND DYING SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. ESPECIALLY IN A
PANDEMIC WE SHOULD BE GIVING
AND INCREASING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND GIVEN THAT CALIFORNIA
IS A LEADER IN THE UNITED
STATES ON A WHOLE RANGE OF
ISSUES THE HELPFUL PROPOSAL IS
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA SHOWED LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA. MY WHOLE DOCUMENT
GRAHAM SUFFERED A TIME. AND
WASN'T ABLE TO GET THE
TREATMENT THAT SHE NEEDED-
UNTIL IT WAS TOO LATE FOR HER
HAND SO I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
CONSIDER IMPLEMENTING CULTURAL.
THE HELP FOR A PROPOSAL FOR THE
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS CAN GET
THE CARE THEY NEED. BUT NIXON
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN HIT HARD BY THE PANDEMIC
AND THAT SHOWN TODAY IN THE
NUMBERS. THE DATA HAS SHOWN
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES MANY OF
WHICH ARE SOCIAL WORKERS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
IMPORTANT SECTORS INCLUDING
AGRICULTURE EDUCATION. OTHER
CRITICAL SECTORS ARE HIT HARD.
INCLUDING I HOPE YOU'LL
CONSIDER GIVING UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ESPECIALLY SENIORS
AN OPTION YOU TO ENRICH THE
LIVES WITH ACTIVE COLLECTION
CARE. BUT IT'S TRULY. CREATE A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT CALL PLEASE.
ALIGN EIGHTY FIVE YOU'RE MY
COULD HELP. EACH CHILD- MY NAME
IS THAT THE VOEPEL AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
KAPLAN AND I'M CALLING FROM LA
CAPSIZES STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
WITH NEARLY EIGHT THOUSAND
SUPPORTERS RANGING FROM
PHYSICIANS HEALTHCARE WORKER
AND PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES WHO
SUPPORT A UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM I AM IN SUPPORT AND
INCLUDING HELP HELP FOR ALL IN
THE STATE BUDGET IT'S AN
ACCEPTABLE THAT OVER A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. ARE LOCKED OUT OF
CARE AND ARE DYING SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS PERSONALLY I HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS STATE FOR DECADES BUT
REMAIN UNDOCUMENTED AND WITHOUT
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND IT
REALLY HURT ME IT'S UNFAIR AND
UNJUST CALIFORNIA MUST REMAIN
THE NATIONAL LEADER IN ENSURING
THAT HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN
RIGHT AGAIN I URGE YOU TO PASS
HELP FOR ALL IN DOCUMENTING
CALIFORNIA NOW TO HELP US GET
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC AND TRULY.
CREATE A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALL PLEASE- LINE AT SIXTY FOUR
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATIE RIGHT
NOT BE HALF OF THE CHILDREN
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX PROGRAMS
THAT HAD A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON OUR MEMBER MEDICAL GROUP
EXACTLY THIS SUPPLEMENTAL
PETITION PAYMENTS HAVE BROUGHT
GREAT CLOSER TO MEDICARE
LEVELS. ROUGHLY 5275% OF OUR
MEMBERS PATIENTS ARE IN MEDIC
HOW INCLUDING MANY INVOLVED IN
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
SERVICES PROGRAM WITH NUMEROUS
REGIONS STILL IN A DEEPER
SERVICE ENVIRONMENT MUCH HAS
NOT SEEN A RATE INCREASE HE
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS. AND DURING
THE CALL THAT CRISIS OUR
POSITION GROUPS HAVE BEEN HIT
HARD FINANCIALLY BY THE LOWER
UTILIZATION. PEDIATRIC HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. AND I THOUGHT
WHAT THE PENA PROGRAM HAVE BEEN
LIFE FINE THE COURT THE FACT
THAT THERE IS. WELL WE WERE
GLAD TO BE THE CLOCK OF THE
SIX. THAT FOR ANOTHER. YEAR THE
BUDGET YEAR WITH THE A. L.
AMPAT COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS
MONEY OF THE MEMBERS COMMENT WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TODAY. WE THE
NEED FOR CONSISTENT AND
STABILITY YOU'RE UPPING YOUR
WITH THESE PROGRAMS. THAT WE
CARE WHAT OUR TO THE BALCONY TO
CONSIDER ELIMINATING THE
CONVENTION. EXCUSE ME. BOB WE
WERE A IN BUT ABOUT YOU ITEM
FOR SECURE CHECK FOR TAKE THAT.
CONTINUE WITH BECAUSE MONITOR
THEM HOW BIG YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM MEXICO PLEASE. ALIGN
EIGHTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
RAMBLING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
DISTANCE JULIE SNYDER
REPRESENTING THE SAME BURKE
INSTITUTE I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE SEVEN
WHICH IS ADDING DNA THE STAFF
TO IMPLEMENT LAST YEAR'S SB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR
WIENER WE WERE PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF THE MEASURE TO DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT IN THE PRIVATE
INSURANCE MARKET. WE
APPRECIATED THE LEGISLATURE
STRONG COMMITMENT TO THE
LEGISLATION AND NOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTED AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. A
LINE AT SEVENTY THREE YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. WHY SPENT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I'M CALLING
REGARDING ITEM NUMBER THREE- WE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX AND THE MEDICAL
OPTION BENEFITS PARTICULAR AT
THE PLAZA PODIATRY THE FOR ALL
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
WE ASK THAT YOU ELIMINATE THE
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE AND MAKE
THOSE PROPOSALS- IN STATUTE OR
IN THE BUDGET. COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIND AT NINETY
ONE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
WHERE A TOP ON BEHALF OF BY A
CON CALIFORNIA. REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE A CGM
COVERAGE FROM MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES. THE MATURE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENT
EARLIER THAT IT IS A PROVEN
THERAPY- FOR THOSE SUFFERING
FROM DIABETES AND LOOK FORWARD
TO THIS PROPOSAL IMPROVING
HEALTH OUTCOMES THANK. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ALAINA
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS IT'S NOT HANDLE THE
BEGINNING THE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBERS FOUR I SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
COERAGE OF CGM'S FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WINE EIGHTY YOUR MY GET UP AND.
HI THIS IS NEAR MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND I'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO ELIMINATE
THAT THE PENSION UP TOP FIFTY
SIX PAYMENTS THAT SUPPORT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH. AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS FOR
ADULT BENEFICIARY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. PINE SEVENTEEN YOUR
MARKETS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS IS GABRIELLE
WHO STARTS FROM DE LOS ANGELES
HEADQUARTERS OF THE NATIONAL
IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER-
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND MEDICAL
COVERAGE TO SENIORS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS-
SENIOR IMMIGRANTS ARE UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THE ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS INCLUDING MEDICARE
MEDICAID AND SOCIAL SECURITY
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TOO MANY
OTHERS SEEING YOURS. THEY HAVE
SUFFERED GREATLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC IMMIGRANTS ARE OVER
REPRESENTED AMONG ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND MANY LIVE IN MULTI
GENERATIONAL HOUSEHOLDS WERE
INJURED SENIORS AS WELL AS
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
EXPOSED AND HAD DIFFICULTY
ISOLATING THIS IS THE MOMENT
WHEN WE REALLY SHOULD ACT AS A
STATE THAT SHOWS MORAL
LEADERSHIP. FOR THE COUNTRY
PLEASE. PASS THE LET'S. I THINK.
HELPED MEDI CAL ACCESS FOR
SENIORS IN THE BUDGET THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ALAINA NINETY THREE
YOUR MIKE IS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR SHARE GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL CLIENTS AND
SUPPORT AT ISSUE FOR YOU ADD
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORING
SYSTEM AS A MEDICAL MEDICARE
BENEFITS FOR BENEFICIARIES WITH
TYPE ONE DIABETES TO
DEMONSTRATE MEDICAL NECESSITY.
THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION SUPPORT
THE COVERAGE OF THE GM FOR ALL
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WITH
DIABETES WHEN PRESCRIBED BY A
DOCTOR AS MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
IN ADDITION THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS
THE COVERAGE OF THESE
LIFESAVING MEDICAL DEVICES
WHICH CAN HELP THE STATE TO
REDUCE SPENDING AND LONG RUN BY
PREVENTING ER VISITS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WELL LINE AT NINETY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI ANDY
HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
I'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON BOTH THE
HELP FOR ALL COMPONENTS AND THE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX COMPONENT
OF THE HEARING TODAY. ON HEALTH
FOR ALL CAMPAIGN SUPPORT ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL PEOPLE WEBER
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED
EXPANSION OF MEDICAL COVERAGE
TO MORE CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF DOCUMENTATION STATUS THE
COURTS CNN'S GOALS FOR IMPROVED
PUBLIC HEALTH AND AN INCREASE
IN PREVENTATIVE CARE. ENSURING
ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE CARE
REDUCES LONG TERM DISABILITY
REDUCES THE IMPACT OF CHRONIC
CONDITIONS AND ULTIMATELY
REDUCES COSTS IN THE SYSTEM AS
PEOPLE PROCEED CONSISTENT CARE
THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO TRY TO
ACCESS CARE FOR THE EMERGENCY
ROOM AFTER THAT CONDITION HAS
WORSENED. ON PROP FIFTY SIX
CLEARLY CMA STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE PROPOSAL TO DELAY THE
SUSPENSION OF SUPPLEMENTAL
PROVIDER PAYMENT CURRENTLY
FUNDED THROUGH PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX BUT REFLECTING THE
COMMENTS OF COREY HIS SEAT AT
THE L. A. L. AND MANY OTHERS
TODAY WE CONTINUE TO QUESTION
THE NEED FOR RETAINING THE
SUSPENSION MECHANISM.
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER PAYMENTS
ARE A KEY TOOL IN INCREASING
ACCESS TO AND QUALITY OF CARE
IN THE MEDICAL SYSTEM AND
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED A
PERMANENT AND FUNDAMENTAL PART
OF THE PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT
STRUCTURE FOR MEDIC CAL
REGARDLESS OF THE SOURCE FROM
BANK. I WANT TO THANK DR WHAT'S
FOR HIS COMMENTS ABOUT A LONG
TERM STRATEGY FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
PROVIDER PAYMENT YEAH MY IT
EAGER TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING THE
FUNDING STRUCTURE FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER PAYMENTS
TO ENSURE STABILITY OF THE
PROVIDER NETWORK MAINTAIN
ACCESS TO CARE FOR MEDI CAL.
BENEFICIARIES AND MAXIMIZE THE
INTENDED POSITIVE EFFECTS. OF
THE PAYMENT THANK YOU. THEY YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER. FIND
NINETEENTH YOU'RE MY COULD HELP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
KATHY THUNDER EXCEL WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF- THE WHOLE FOR ALL PROPOSAL
AND ARE PLEASED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IN PARTICULAR WE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A GLOBAL COMMENT
RELATED TO- CHANGES SUCH AS THE
HEALTH FOR ALL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE AUTOMATION AND TOWNIE
ELIGIBILITY SYSTEM. AS YOU'RE
AWARE WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
MIGRATING TO A SINGLE SYSTEM AS
PER FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AND
THAT SCREEN IS ON THE TRACKS
WERE STARTING THAT SEASON LATER
THIS YEAR AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING INVOLVED IN
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THE
FINAL PACKAGE. BOTH IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WORLD
AS THE TIME FOR AUTOMATING
CHANGES SUCH AS THAT WILL
REALLY DEPEND ON WHAT THE
OVERALL PACKAGE LOOKS LIKE WE
REALLY ENCOURAGE- YOU AND YOUR
STAFF AND THOSE WHO PUT FORWARD
PROPOSALS TO ENGAGE WITH US
EARLY. SO WE CAN OFFER IDEAS
FOR HOW- SOMETHING MAYBE
APPROACH MORE SIMPLY OR MORE
COMPLEX AND GIVE SUGGESTIONS
THAT COULD EASE THE AUTOMATION
FOR- AS MANY OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT WE SUPPORT- THAT ARE OUT
THERE THAT ARE GREAT PROPOSALS
AS POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THEY
CAN BE IMPLEMENTED IN A TIMELY
A MANNER AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU
AND APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THE
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE-
LINE AT NINETY NINE YOUR MIKE
IT UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JIM WHEN BURKE AND I'M
CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
THAT CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
EXPANDING MEDIKAL ACCESS TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE SENIORS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS
PAY BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
TAXES THEY PERFORM THE
ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS THAT HAVE
ENABLED LIKE TO CARRY ON DURING
THE PANDEMIC. AND YET THEY ARE
EXCLUDED FROM MEDICARE OR
MEDICAID. THEY ARE EXCLUDED
FROM FEDERAL STIMULUS PAYMENTS
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
OTHER IMPORTANT SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS WHILE WE DO APPRECIATE
CONTEMPORARY PROGRAMS FOR THE
UNINSURED TO ACCESS COLD COLD
IT RELATED CARE. THIS IS NOT
NEARLY THE SAME AS BOTH
PROGRAMMATIC CAL ESPECIALLY FOR
PEOPLE IN THEIR LATER YEARS. AS
A MATTER OF BASIC FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY AND IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT THE HEALTH.
FOR ALL PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER. FIND
A ONE HUNDRED YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MANAGING KANSEN SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK WHICH IS A
STATEWIDE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WORKING TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING A BLACK
CALIFORNIANS. SHOULD BE H. AND
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE BUDGET
REQUEST REGARDING THE EXPANSION
OF MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
ABOUT IMMIGRATION STATUS NOW
THE TIME TO PRIORITIZE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH EQUITY AND
DOING SO REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE AND CARE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS.
ABOUT ACCESS TO PREVENTIVE
ERVICES AS A KEY COMPONENT TO
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES
REDUCING HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
ADDRESSING HEALTH DISPARITIES
REGION ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE BUDGET REQUEST TO PROVIDE
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WITH
DIABETES ACCESS TO CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
DIABETES AND HAVE SEPARATE
TREMENDOUSLY TO DIABETES
RELATED COPA NINETEEN
COMPLICATIONS. THIS BUDGET
REQUEST WOULD INCREASE ACCESS
TO A TOOL THAT IS CRITICAL TO
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES EXACTLY HM
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO ELIMINATE
PROPERTY SIX SUSPENSIONS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
ONE AND ONE YOU'RE MY COULD
HELP. SH THIS IS FOR GONZALEZ
WITH NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND WE'RE CALLING TO
DATE TO SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER
ONE HELP FOR ALL SENIORS- THIS
IS ALWAYS BEEN A PRIORITY FOR
OUR ORGANIZATION BUT ESPECIALLY
NOW DURING TOPIC NINETEEN- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I IN ORDER TO
HAVE- ADEQUATE AND GOOD PUBLIC
HEALTH EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE
COVERED. ALSO WE ARE CALLING IN
SUPPORT AND ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
TO SUPPORT STAFF POSITION TO
ENFORCE MENTAL HEALTH PARITY-
AS A RESULT OF S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE OF LAST YEAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE AT NINETY
FOUR YOUR MY GET UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR REGULARLY
MEMBERS ONLY MAC MILLER I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DELEGATION ON THREE
ISSUES. EIGHTY ONE THE
CALIFORNIA BOTH. ORDER OF THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND MANY
ELIGIBILITY TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED DON'T AND
FOR WHAT MANY CALLIN CLUES
DENTAL COVERAGE WITH ANGELA
OVERALL HEALTH. FOR EFFORT
PROVED ACT CARE AS WELL OVERALL
HEALTH AT ALL FREE BY ANY
NUMBER OF ORAL HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE TO GROUPS THAT HAVE
BEEN TRADITIONALLY ON IN THIRD.
YOU HAVE BEEN WITHOUT ACT. WHAT
HEALTH PRO. COMMERCE ON
INSURANCE HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATURE MUST ENSURE THAT
MEDICARE PROGRAM REMAIN
ADEQUATELY FUNDED AND THAT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE EFFICIENT
SUPPORT THE PROVISION OF CARE.
ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO WE'D LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT HOW HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
THANK GOODNESS AND FOR
COMMITTING AND THE TELEHEALTH
FLEXIBILITY THAT WERE ALLOWED
DURING THE PANDEMIC IN THEIR
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL.
HOWEVER WE WERE DISAPPOINTED TO
SEE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OR THE
BILL LANGUAGE DID NOT INCLUDE
THE ABILITY TO ESTABLISH A
PATIENT THROUGH EIGHT
DIFFERENT. COLOR HEALTH.
VERTICAL TEMPLE HOME MODELS.
IT'S ALL EVIDENCE WE HAVE
MODELS- ALL HEALTHY WHICH
DENTAL HYGIENISTS IN THE-
BUILDING COMMUNITY SITE PROVIDE
AGNOSTIC PREVENTED AND EARLY
INTERVENTION I DON'T CARE. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COLLABORATING
AND IT- REVIEWS RECORDS
REMOTELY THE DEPARTMENT
LANGUAGE BUT THE POTENTIAL
UNDERMINE THE BIG DEBTS IT
INCURRED. OVER WELL DONE HEALTH
PROGRAM- ON EIGHTY THREE
IDIOTS. OR EXPANSION OF PROFIT
RATE INCREASES. RIGHT FOR THE
STATE BANK PAYMENT FOR MALCOLM
PROGRAM WE HAVE BEEN A MEDIC
CAL DENTAL PROGRAMS OVER THE
RECENT YEARS. THAT INCREASE
BOTH THE NUMBER OF AND ROLLED
IN THE PROGRAM AND THE AMOUNT
OF CARE BEING PROVIDED. WE
APPRECIATE THE JANUARY
BUDGETING- INCLUDE THE GENERAL
FUND BACK FILL FOR THE PROPERTY
RIGHT MAKE IT HAPPEN. HE AGREED
WITH THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
LA- ABOUT THE LARGER STRUCTURAL
ISSUES FOR PROPERTY OPPOSITION
FIFTY EXPANDING AND STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THE LEFT FIFTY.
CONVERSATION ABOUT ABLE LIGHTEN
MANY CALORIES. ALONG THANK.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER.
ALAINA ONE FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD
HELP. GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR AND
MEMBER MICROCAR HERE I'M HAPPY
CAL K. ABOUT AND HEARING AND
THAT PATIENTS THROUGHOUT THE
BOTH ADULTS CHILDREN. I CAN
PROVIDE INPUT ISSUES SIX LAST
THE ONGOING CONTINUING OF FROM
THAT OR CAL OPS AUDIO BENEFITS.
WITHOUT PROPER DIAGNOSIS
HEARING LOSS AN APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT HEARING AIDS
CALIFORNIA HEARING IMPAIRED
CORE LOCAL LEVEL ABILITY TO
HEAR AND COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY. THIS HANDICAP AND
TERM PRODUCES PRODUCTIVITY AND
QUALITY OF LIFE DON'T AFFECTED
WITH UNTREATED HEARING LOSS
SEPARATE FROM THE HEIGHTENED
ASSUMING THAT IN DEPRESSION IN
CHILDREN WHO ARE NOT AFFORD
EARLY INTERVENTION ARE
SUBJECTED TO INCREASE RISK
OPENING DEFICIENCIES AND BEING
PROBLEMS THAT WILL IMPACT THEM
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THEIR
LIVES. UP TO HAVE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SUPPORT NOT
FILLING UP THE TV ELIMINATION
OF THE SUSPENSION LANGUAGE. AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. A
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED SEVEN YOUR
MIKE ITSELF AND- HELLO THIS IS
CUANDO BUSCABA FIFTEEN KEEPING
COORDINATOR FOR ACTION CALLING
FOR ISSUE NUMBER ONE HELPER
ALL. EIGHT IS A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION INCLUDING A
MEMBERSHIP BASED AND COOKED-
WHICH PROVIDES AN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER'S
DISTRICT. OF SO MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED SO
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED. IT IS TIME TO
EXPAND MEDICAL LECTURE TO ALL
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND. TO
ENSURE A JUST HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIND ONE HUNDRED
NINE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. HI
EVERYONE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS CYNTHIA WALKS BUT CENTER
ENES KNOCKED ON THE SETTLING IN
THE SONOMA HIKING I'M HERE
TODAY TO BE MY MOTHER'S VOICE
FAMILY MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY
AND THE REASON I'M SAYING THAT
I'M GOING TO BE THEIR VOICE TO
THE BECAUSE OF THE- MY MOTHER
MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS WE SPEAK
AN INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE CLOCK
SUBTROPICAL- DUE TO A LANGUAGE
BARRIER THEY CAN GIVE THEIR
TESTIMONY TODAY BOBBY HERE TO
BE THEIR VOICE. AND I URGE YOU
ALL TO SUPPORT AND PASSED
HEALTH FOR ALL REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS THEY HAVE
BEEN DIFFICULT TO SEE MY MOTHER
DECIDING BETWEEN PAYING RENT OR
HAVING TO PAY HER HEALTH
COVERAGE COST AND OUR POCKETS.
HEALTH CARE SHOULD BE A HUMAN
RIGHT LET'S CONTINUE TO BE THE
GOLDEN STATE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS LET'S CONTINUE TO
BE THE LEADER IN THE NATION BY
PROVIDING HEALTH COVERAGE. TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WELL I KNOW ONE HUNDRED
ELEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD HELP.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MEGAN TO BURKE ON BEHALFOF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING NEARLY FOURTEEN
HUNDRED COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS THAT PROVIDE COMPLEMENT
COMPREHENSIVE PRIMARY CARE TO
SEVEN POINT FOUR YOU CAN
CALIFORNIANS. AND ONE IN THREE
MEDIC HELP PATIENT BURBERRY
PROP TO PORTER ISSUE NUMBER ONE
HEALTH FOR ALL AND WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ITEM. AND
THAT'S QUOTABLE COLBERT
NINETEEN RESPONSE WILL NOT BE
POSSIBLE WITHOUT COVERAGE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN N THE FOREFRONT OF
EXPANDING HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
AND ACCESS. I'M NOT CONTINUE
LEADING THE NATION IN THIS
ISSUE COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
URGE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO RECOMMIT TO
MEDICARE COVERAGE FOR ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINE TWENTY THREE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. EVERYBODY
MY NAME IS KARINA- I WORK WITH
THE LANGUAGE AND GET RIGHTS
COALITION OUR ORGANIZATION
WORKS WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE HOUSE
BUT A LACK OF HEALTH COVERAGE
THAT ARE NOT JUST LATIN ACTS
BUT ARE ALSO OF VARIOUS
ETHNICITIES. I'M THINKING OF OR
SAUDIA WHO HAS HAD HEALTH
ISSUES- HER HEARING IS. QUICKLY
DEPLETING BUT SHE HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO BE MEDICALLY TREATED.
AND I ALSO THINK OF MY OWN
FATHER WHO WORKS DAY IN AND DAY
OUT IN THE HOT SUN AND HOME I
WORRY MAY HAVE. SKIN CANCER. WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS
INITIATIVE DUE TO THE LACK OF
HEALTH COVERAGE MANY
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE RELIANT
HOME REMEDIES AND OR EMERGENCY
ROOMS TO CARE FOR THEIR HEALTH
CONDITIONS. IT'S UNACCEPTABLE
THAT MILLIONS OF UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS HAVE GIVEN THEIR
BODIES TO THE ECONOMY OF THE
STATE. HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ARE STILL
EXCLUDED FROM HEALTH COVERAGE
AGAIN. WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
HEALTH FOR ALL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ALAINA ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. HELLO MY
NAME IS LUKA GIVE OFF I'M WITH
BUILDINGS LEGAL CENTER TOPIC IS
A REGIONAL BASE BUILDING.
ORGANIZING IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND COACHELLA VALLEY- TODAY I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EXPANDING
MEDICARE FOR SENIORS TO HELP
ALL ELDERS IF IT'S NOT NOW WHEN
WILL IT BE THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUE TO SHED LIGHT ON THE
INEQUALITIES THAT HAVE EXISTED
FOR YEARS. WE CONTINUE SEEN OUR
MEMBERS ARE FARMWORKERS AND
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS DIE.
OUR ELDERS HAVE TAKEN THEIR
LIVES. OW GIVEN THEIR LIVES TO
THE ECONOMY OF OUR STATE IT IS
TIME TO GET BACK TO PROTECT
THOSE THAT ARE STILL ALIVE- WE
RECENTLY HAD. WE HAVE MANY OF
OUR FARMWORKERS OUR ELDERS PASS
AWAY- MOST RECENTLY WE HAD ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS THAT HE WAS
SCARED TO BE BEEN GOING TO THE
DOCTOR. BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF
PUBLIC CHARGING NOT HAVING
HEALTH CARE. HIS DAUGHTER FOUND
HIM DEAD IN THE MORNING. THESE
ARE THE STORIES THAT WE'RE
HEARING EVERY DAY. EVERY DAY
AND NOW WITH THE PANDEMIC WE
CONTINUE HEARING THE MORE AND
MORE AND MARK. THIS IS VERY
PERSONAL TO ORGANIZATIONS AND
WE ARE THIS IS AS WE CONTINUE
SEEN OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THAT'S THE WAY. THE FACT
STORIES GIVEN THIS DAY BAKER TO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT. AN ADVOCATE
FOR HEALTH PROBLEMS. NOW I ASK
ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE STEP UP.
YOUR CONSCIENCE AND COMPASSION
AND EXPAND HELP BROKERAGE FOR
ALL OUR WAY LOOK THE OTHER WAY
I THINK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
FOR YOUR STRENGTHENED HER
PASSION. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ALAINA SEVENTY NINE YOUR MIKE
IT'S OPEN. ERIC PAIN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
URBAN INSTITUTE WE REPRESENT
THE VOICES OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WE STAND AS STRONG SUPPORT OF
HEALTH FROGS AND DR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND SO
EXPAND MEDICAL COVERAGE OF
SENIORS A POPULAR MISCONCEPTION
IS THAT IMMIGRATION IS THE A
LATIN ACT ISSUE. DURING
IMMIGRANT RIGHT COMPLICATED
PEOPLE WOULD ASK ONE OF OUR
RESIDENTS WHERE DO BLACK
IMMIGRANTS COME FROM AND WHY
HAVEN'T I HEARD YOU SPEAK
SPANISH SHE WOULD TELL THEM
BLACK IMMIGRANTS COME FROM THE
SAME PLACE YOU COME FROM AN END
TO THE SECOND QUESTION SHE
WOULD ANSWER SPAM IS THAT THE
MARKER FOR IMMIGRANT IDENTITY
IMMIGRANTS COME FROM ALL ACROSS
THE GLOBE. I REMIND YOU OF THIS
FACT BECAUSE THE MEDIA HAS THE
RIGHT THE BLACK EXPERIENCE FROM
THE IMMIGRANT NARRATIVE THE
IMPLICATION IS THAT BLACK
IMMIGRANT DISAPPEARING PLAIN
SIGHT WE GET LEFT OUT OF
CONVERSATIONS RELATIVE TO THE
FUTURE OF IMMIGRANTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE CAME AT
ALLIED INSTEAD OF INDIVIDUALS
BEING DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE
ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION. BLACK
IMMIGRANTS DO EXIST THERE YOUR
NANNY'S YOUR ELDERLY CARETAKERS
ARE HOUSEKEEPERS AND OTHER
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES
TO ENSURE OUR FAMILIES ARE FED
LABORING IN OUR PROCESSING
PLANT AND THE CHILLING AFFECT
KOBE NINETEEN HAS HAD ON OUR
FAMILY HAS SHED LIGHT ON WORKER
CONDITIONS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND THE DISPROPORTIONATE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF ACCESS TO CARE HAVE
BEEN JARRING- WEEKEND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ALAINA ALL HUNDRED TEN
YOUR MIKE HELP. HELLO MY NAME
IS PHOEBE ABRAMOWITZ AM WITH
ACTOR HELLO THE CAN ADVOCATES
COALITION FOR HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES. I'M CALLING TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE HEALTH
FOR ALL CAMPAIGN I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL LISTEN TO THE STORIES
THAT YOU HEARD TODAY AND THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OTHER
ELDERLY CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY BEING DENIED
HEALTHCARE SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. AND I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL SEE THE
URGENCY AND THE NEED BECAUSE
UNDOCUMENTED SENIOR CAN'T WAIT
ANY LONGER TO STOP BEING
EXCLUDED FROM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
AT ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI THIS
IS I'M HAVING TROUBLE WITH THE
U. S. MEXICO BORDER PROGRAM OF
THE AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE INCENDIO CALIFORNIA
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL I'M NOT
REALLY FOR SENIORS BUT IT
SHOULD BE FOR ALL. WORK MICHAEL
WORKERS WHO WORK IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESOURCES-
THAT AND WHILE THAT IS CREATED
BY MICHAEL LABOR WHETHER BE IN
THE FIELDS. IN CONSTRUCTION. IN
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. ALL
THE WAY AROUND THE ECONOMY
BENEFITS. FROM MIGRANT LABOR
AND IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
HEALTHCARE IS A FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN RIGHT. THERE ARE
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD THAT
HAVE DONE THIS AND HAVE
CREATED. SYSTEMS TO PROTECT-
WORKERS. YOU KNOW AND THAT ANY
ANYTHING DURING TIMES OF
PANDEMICS SO WE SHOULD BECAUSE-
RIGHT HEALTHCARE FOR ALL AND IF
THEY CAN DO IT. WE KNOW THAT
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO IT SO-
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ALIGNER ONE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
SO THIS IS DANIEL SABINO WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE THREE RELATED
TO PROP FIFTY SIX AND
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS PAYMENT
SUSPENSION AGAIN KEEPING WITH
OUR ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF
DELAYING AND ULTIMATELY
ELIMINATING PAYMENT SUSPENSIONS
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WERE
ALSO SUPPORTER OF THESE ISSUES
THESE SERVICES TREMENDOUSLY
BENEFIT PEOPLE FROM OTHER
DISABILITIES THAT WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT STABILITY FOR
PROVIDERS WITH PAYMENT RATES IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR PROVIDING
STABILITY TO THEIR LONG TERM
SERVICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN YOUR MIKE
IS UP. HELLO MY NAME IS OSCAR
SANDOVAL AND I AM THE SENIOR
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR
THE LATINO COALITION FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA I'M JUST
GOING TO THEIR ORGANIZATION
STRONGLY SUPPORTS EXPANDING
MEDICAL COVERAGE TO ALL SENIORS
NO MATTER WHAT THEIR-
DOCUMENTATION THAT IT IS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE AT ONE HUNDRED
TWELVE YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR ARAMBULA
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THIS IS FELIX TO COMPLETION
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING
TODAY ON ISSUE ONE ON HEALTH
FOR ALL WHICH SO MANY OTHERS OF
SPOKEN ELOQUENTLY ABOUT HOW WE
ARE A NOT FOR PROFIT MISSION
DRIVEN HEALTH PLAN THAT SERVES
OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEDICAID MEMBERS TODAY. OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE
BEEN THRILLED TO WELCOME
THOUSANDS OF MILLION SURE
CHILDREN AND ADULTS TO THE
SECURITY OF HEALTH COVERAGE
UNDER A PLAN THANKS TO
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN
PROVIDING FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
TO THESE POPULATIONS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE
APPLAUD FURTHER MOVES TO CLOSE
THE STATE'S REMAINING GAP OF
THREE MILLION UNINSURED
RESIDENTS AND WE WERE IN FACT
THE FIRST HEALTH PLAN TO PUSH
FOR STATEWIDE UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE AND WE HAVE NOT HEARD
SINCE WE REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT BY SUPPORTING THE
GOAL. OF MEDI CAL TO FULLY
COVER ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
ADULTS AND ESPECIALLY SENIORS
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ALAINA HUNDRED TWENTY.
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. EVERYTHING
WILL BUT IT'S JUST A LOT OF
MONDAY WHEN I LOOKED AT THE DNA
LEVEL NINETEEN NINETY ADMITTED
KEEPS IT THEREFORE YOU HAVE A
LOT OF TROUBLES TO CATER
TELEMEDICINE THE NEXT- SALUTE
FOOD SAFETY TECHNICAL. SOME OF
THE ONE DOLLAR THERMODYNAMICS
IF THIS DENNIS WHO AND TO THE-
NOTHING EVER. YEAH CALIF
DILUTES THE MEDICAL YES YES AND
I SAID YOU'RE A NEXT PLEASE.
LAINO HUNDRED TWENTY THREE YOUR
ITSELF AND- I GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBER MY IS
GREG MATH THE DAY PRO AND
POLICY FOR. HEALTH AND THAT
LAUNCHED. OUR MISSION TO.
CONNECT NOW CHILDREN FAMILY AND
OTHER DOPEST AFFORD AND HEALTH
AND SOCIAL. AND I'M CALLING
REGARDING REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER ONE I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT HEALTH FOR ALL IN THE
EFFORT TO EXPAND HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL. IN ORANGE COUNTY WE
HAVE WELL OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND THAT ARE UNINSURED DUE
TO THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AND CURRENTLY AS YOU PROBABLY
HEARD A COVER CALIFORNIA SAID
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND THAT ARE
UNINSURED. AND ELIGIBLE FOR THE
SUBSIDY TO APPLY FOR HEALTH
INSURANCE BUT THEY HAVEN'T.
ACCORDING TO A MARCH FIRST
STUDY FROM UCLA CENTER FOR
HEALTH POLICY AND RESEARCH. 27%
OF THOSE ALREADY LAWFUL
LOUGHREY PERMANENT RESIDENTS
REPORTING A BOY. RESIDENTS
REPORTED AVOIDING PUBLIC
SYSTEMS PROGRAMS AGAIN I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE HELP FOR ALL
LEGISLATION I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND- COMMITMENT TO
HELP FOR ALL. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE AT ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE YOUR MIKE
IT'S OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NATHAN CHEUNG AND I'M
CALLING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF HEALTH WELL. AS
RESTAURANT WORKER I'VE WORKED
WITH MANY UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
WHO HADN'T BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS
HEALTH CARE WHEN SUFFERING FROM
THINGS LIKE FAT BURN AND LOSE.
AND AS AN IMMIGRANT MYSELF I'VE
OFTEN THOSE CLOSEST TO ME NOT
BE ABLE TO GO TO A DOCTOR WHEN
SICK RELYING ON UNSAFE REMEDY
STUFF AND MINISTERING SHOT ALL
WHAT PAYING OUT OF POCKET AND
WORKING IN THE FINANCIAL
INDUSTRY. MANY OF YOU HERE
TODAY. ON THE- WITH AFTER TO
HEALTH. IN ADDITION TO A STABLE
JOB AND INCOME DURING THAT
CONDEMNED. AND THE LACK OF
AFTER THE HEALTH CARE COOLEY
ONE OF THE MANY WAYS IN WHICH
IT HAS CONTINUED TO THE
MEDICALLY EXCLUDE IMMIGRANTS.
AND IT IS HERE I ASK YOU ALL TO
CHANGE THAT TODAY THAT'S
ACCORDING HEALTH FOR ALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ALAINA ALL ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX- MY COULD HELP.
HELLO DOCTOR ARE BLANK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANDREA YES AND I'M A COMMUNITY
MEMBER OF MARIN COUNTY AND
PROGRAM COORDINATOR PERCENT OF
INACTION MATCH FOR THE DEMOCRAT
DEVELOPMENT OF INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY- MANY MINORITY
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING IMPACTED
BY COLLUDED IN OTHER HEALTH
DISPARITIES IT IS IMPORTANT
HAVE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL I
THINK THERE'S A HUMAN RIGHT. TO
HAVE ACCESS TO IT WE HAVE
WAITED TOO LONG SEEM TO MUCH
AND I AM NOT TO MAKE ANY CHANGE
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY NO ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR MIKE IT'S
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS ERIC BOLLING OF OUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP ON ISSUE ONE AS THE
COMPANY NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
MADE CLEAR THE HEALTH OF EACH
ELECT THE DEEPLY INTERCONNECTED
WITH THAT OF EVERY CALIFORNIANS
AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
OUR CHILDREN'S GRANDPARENTS IN
THE U. S. CARE FOR ONE OUT OF
FOUR CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
FIVE. WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSED EXPANSION OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR COKE MEDICARE
BENEFITS TO ALL PERSONS AGE
SIXTY FIVE YEARS AND OLDER
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AN ISSUE THREE ARM IN
ADDITION TO MR DELAYED
PEDIATRIC APPOINTMENTS FOR
CHILDREN MANY PEDIATRIC
PEDIATRICIAN ARE FACING
UNCERTAIN FINANCIAL FUTURES DUE
TO THE REDUCED QUALITY
REPLACEMENTS DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. ELIMINATING THE
PAYMENT THREATENS THE VERY
EXISTENCE OF OUR STATE HE
ACTION PROVIDER SYSTEM WHO ARE
FURTHER DESTABILIZED DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE BUDGET SHOULD
THEREFORE MAKE THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS PERMANENT INSTEAD OF
DELAYED THERE'S A GEN PER. YEAR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MA'AM
NOT CALLER PLEASE. ALAINA ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN-
HELLO- MY NAME IS LOSING A LOT
OF- I. YOU CAN ONLY HAVE LIKE
ME FOR LUBBOCK OR- I WILL
DOCUMENT AND I'M- I'M HERE JUST
OUR HELP FOR ALL OF THE NEW WE
SHOULD BE ARE TO HEALTH CARE BE
ON THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. IT
IS TIME TO PULL A POSITIVE ARE
TALKING. WHICH IS SAID BUT
STATES- WE ALL ARE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO LIFE LIBERTY AND THE
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS- THAT IS
ALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ANIME CHAIR
THERE ARE FURTHER PEOPLE
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMON.
OPERATOR CAN YOU RUN THE LIST
ONE MORE TIME TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS. WE
CAN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMENTATOR THAT- COMMAND AGAIN
ONE THEN. AND WE DO HAVE MORE
PEOPLE- QUEUING UP TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT JUST BE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF THE
OTHER SURPLUS EDL CLUBS IN THE
AREA NUMBER AND CONCORD OF THE
YEAR. YOU HAVE TO CONNECT WITH
OTHER LIVES ON UPON MY
INTELLECT BIGELOW INDIANA. AND
THAT'S ANOTHER OF MODERN AND
LOOK AT IT AGAIN S. OF THE
PUBLIC IN MONTHS ONLY THE CLIFF
KNOCKS. NOT IF YOU WANT AND ON
YOU MIGHT WANT TO BLAME AND
PROCESS PROBLEM THIRTY
ASAMBLEíSTA HARD IS ANY LAST
THOSE CAN AGAIN ACCESS ALL OF
OUR- SO GUN ON A- ON A CLINIC
CAL NOT THAT. AT POLITICAL
STUNT COMPLETED IN A STATES WE
WANT OTHER USE ON A PERSONAL
MILLIONS. A SINGLE MOMENT BY
THE STANDIN BUT IT'S AN WILL
MOST MODESTO MOTHERS PLANT.
EXTEND INTO THE MANTA BY- IT OF
A FIX ON THIS IS MUSCLE I CAME
UNDER AND- OKAY ON COMBAT ON
YOU PASS IN HELLO FOR- IN
OAKLAND OF CLIFF- BUT I YOU ARE
NOT AND IT UP AND YEAH. YOU GET
OUT OF THURMOND CALLING BUT UP
THE LIST DIVIDENDS OF THOSE.
FIRST NURSING HOME RESIDENT
DUMPING CASE IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE AND I'VE BEEN FIGHTING
THEM EVER SINCE. THE CURRENT
LAWS DO BALANCE THE CONCERNS OF
FACILITIES WITH THE PROTECTIONS
OF RESIDENCE. AND IT GIVES
FACILITIES A LEGAL DISCHARGE
PROCESS BUT IT REQUIRES NOTICE
TO THE RESIDENT A RIGHT TO
APPEAL. AND IT GIVES
FACILITIES- SIX REASONS THAT
THEY CAN DISCHARGE RESIDENTS
LEGALLY. BUT THE LAW DOES NOT
ALLOW THEM. TO DUMP RESIDENTS
IN THE HOSPITALS ARE MOTELS ARE
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND ABANDON
THEM THERE. WITHOUT ANY NOTICE
OR OPPORTUNITY TO OBJECT. THE
REASON RESIDENT DUMPING
CONTINUES IS BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN NO ENFORCEMENT FOR SO
LONG- FACILITIES DON'T BOTHER
WITH THE LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE THE CONSEQUENCES ARE SO
MINIMAL IF THERE ANY
CONSEQUENCES AT ALL. THE LAW
ALREADY A- THE CONCERNS VOICED
BY CALF. THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DISCHARGE RESIDENTS BUT THEY
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE PROCESS. THE
HEARINGS ARE MORE THAN FAIR
FACILITIES TYPICALLY LOSE A
HEARINGS NOT BECAUSE THE
REASONS ARE NOT HEARD BUT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE COMPLETELY
IGNORED THE LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
AND PERFORMED AN UNSAFE. AND
ULTIMATELY INDEFENSIBLE
DISCHARGE SO KUDOS TO DH CS FOR
ADDRESSING THIS LONGSTANDING
AND LAMENTABLE PROBLEM FOR
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY NO ONE HUNDRED FIVE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES SIR. HI THIS IS
A BARBIE CALLING ON OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION ASSOCIATION
CALLING ABOUT FIFTY SIX
PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS URGING-
WE SUPPORT OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO ELIMINATE THE
SUSPENSION BATES AND TO PROVIDE
PERMANENT- COVERAGE FOR THE SUB
PAY DID NOT EMERGENCY TEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. THE LION ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY YOUR MARKETS OPEN.
I DON'T WANT OKAY NOT IT YEAH.
YOU KNOW OUR SHE NOT A LITERAL.
INDEED. LAST. IN ORDER. YEAH IN
THAT EIGHT EIGHT FOLLOWED BY
THE NUMBER THE- BATTLE BUT YOU
CAN. CAN ASSIST SONORA NEXT
CALL PLEASE. ALAINA ONE EIGHT
YOUR MIKE AT THE OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN'S CHOICE
DENTAL CARE. HEADQUARTERED IN
SACRAMENTO AND SEVENTEEN
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT- THE STATE
WE WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR EXTENDING THE SUSPENSION BY
ONE YEAR. BUT AS OF MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND DOCTOR WOULD
IN PARTICULAR- COMMENTED. THAT
A SINGLE YEAR EXTENSION IS NOT
A STABILIZING EVENT- AND THAT
WHAT IS NEEDED IS ONGOING AND
STABLE FUNDING. SO THAT
PROVIDERS KNOW HOW TO PLAN BOTH
IN TERMS OF THEIR SERVICES AND
THE NUMBER OF LOCATIONS THEY
HAVE BUT ULTIMATELY THAT THE
PATIENTS CAN RELY ON THEIR
PROVIDERS. BEING THERE FROM
YEAR TO YEAR- SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE- COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
HOW DO WE ENSURE STABLE FUNDING
SO THAT PROVIDERS CAN RELY ON
IN A PREDICTABLE FASHION. AND
THAT THE PATIENTS CAN RELY ON
THE PROVIDERS BEING THERE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND MISTER
CHAIR AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PEOPLE WISHING TO
PROVIDE COMMENT LETTERS TO ONE
FINAL CHECK. BEFORE WE CLOSE
OUT TODAY'S HEARING OPERATOR
PLEASE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
NINE ZERO. AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE NO FURTHER PEOPLE QUEUING
UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WITH THAT I WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE DíAS THANKED THE
MEMBERS FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY- THANK THE STAFF IN
PARTICULAR ANDREA MARGOLIS AND-
THAT WILL COMPLETE TODAY'S
HEARING OF SOMEONE. WE ARE
ADJOURNED.